[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on tient pas le suspense on y va
comment vous allez aujourd'hui j'espère
que vous allez bien bienvenue dans ce
live Youtube où on va parler de
smartphone mais on va pas parler que de
smartphone on va parler beaucoup de
smartphone mais pas uniquement de
smartphone je prends la main là je
regarde si tout marche bien alors
attendez je suis multi-écran c'est le
bordel ici je vous raconte pas comment
est-ce que vous entendez bien déjà j'ai
un œil dans le chat je vous regarde il y
a un setup qui a beaucoup changé
normalement j'ai un seul ordinateur là
j'ai trois j'ai toujours un se
ordinateur mais j'ai trois écrans c'est
la folie de tous les côtés je vous
regarde là je vois qu'il y a du monde
qui vient de anger il y a du monde de
Cholet il y a du monde un peu tous les
côtés vous êtes nombreux nombreuses
merci d'être là au rendez-vous on va
parler bien évidemment de smartphone on
va aussi passer un peu de temps ensemble
parce que moi j'aime passer du temps
avec vous et ça ça me plaît énormément
et puis et puis voilà c'est la joie
c'est c'est c'est c'est bonheur alors je
regarde un peu les messages je vois que
j'ai la team S23 plus qui est dans le
chat avec fost un grand coucou à tout le
monde qui qui qui qui prennent la peine
de venir passer du temps avec nous
Anthony on a Hotman qui est là salut à
toi salut à darkedy alors il y a un
petit décalage entre le moment où moi je
vous vois vos messages et le moment où
je vous parle forcément en plus le chat
est en mode ralenti histoire que je
puisse voir vos messages il y a beaucoup
de monde hein
euh je regarde un petit peu il y a
Delphine qui est là également il y a en
Chel il y a du monde du monde Thomas
également là salut à tous alors j'espère
que ça roule al je vous explique un peu
le concept du live de ce soir alors
avant qu'on parle du concept ça bloque
l'image je voudrais que vous me disiez
si chez vous il y a des bugs ou pas
est-ce que l'image est bonne ou pas je
peux modifier quelques paramètres dans
Obs mais il a planté tout à l'heure donc
j'aimerais bien qu'il plante pas des
masses on est comment là attendez
laissez-moi jeter un petit coup d'œil je
voudrais vraiment que ça plante pas ça
évite les blagues je pense que j'ai
peut-être un débit qui un petit peu trop
élevé je vais redescendre le débit
hop comme ça enfin pas trop élevé mais
un débit un peu fort voilà on va
regarder vous me direz he si tout marche
bien s'il y a des plantages pas des
plantages moi je vaux être sûr que ça
fonctionne bien des fois AC ces petits
outil on a des surprises
euh là est-ce que vous m'avez toujours
euh tac
tac voilà c'est connecté j'ai
l'impression que ça marche je regarde de
mon côté j'ai l'impression que la div
continue dites-le-moi bien dans les
commentaires bug vidéo salut donc on a
un bug vidéo c'est pas ouf j'ai fait des
modifs donc on va regarder si ça marche
euh tac tac tac batteur qui nous dit
salut monsieur Greux plaisir de te voir
en live j'adore tes vidéos merci
beaucoup il y a des sacades ça sacade ça
lag alors attendez je vais attendre voir
parce que le moment où je lis vos
messages et le moment où ça modifiait
normalement ça devrait aller un peu
mieux dites-moi si ça fonctionne bien
normalement j'ai un ordi qui doit
fonctionner ça ça cade encore un peu
chez moi l'image ça cade le son est ok
on va quand même pas faire un podcast
audio il faut avoir un peu d'image quand
même alors je regarde si je peux encore
modifier deux trois trucs directement
sur sur Obs on fait des tests en direct
voyez comme ça on est on est au top on a
un peu de temps de toute façon on n'est
pas trop pressé je sais pas si vous êtes
pressé moi j'ai mon temps j'ai toute ma
soirée je l'ai calé que pour vous que
pour qu'on passe du temps ensemble
euh je vais je vais je vais je pense
mettre ça comme ça je vais mettre ça
comme ça j'espère que ça va pas couper
normalement ça devrait aller et allez on
va regarder avec des nouveaux nouveaux
paramètres voir si ça
fonctionne dites-moi vous de votre côté
ce que ça raconte les paramètres ont été
modifiés et j'espère que ça va le faire
je regarder un petit peu ce que vous me
dites attendant je regarde vos messages
euh salut du Maroc et salut à tous les
amis qui sont qui sont partout dans le
monde déjà marocains vos voisins
tunisiens voisins algériens également à
tout le monde à l'Afrique continent
africain on passe le bonjour à tout le
monde salut à Christophe qui nous passe
un grand coucou Shazam
àadeus je vois qu'il y a des petits
messages je regarde un petit peu c'est
pas fluide la vidéo est-ce que ça va
mieux je vais essayer de pas trop bouger
est-ce que la vidéo va mieux ou pas
normalement ça devrait aller il y en a
c'est on va pas commencer comme ça salut
Christophe salut dor coucou à toutes les
personnes qui nous écoutent dors
dites-moi d'aurs première chose où
est-ce que vous êtes à quel endroit
géographique est-ce que vous vous
situez est-ce que vous êtes en France
est-ce que vous êtes pas en France
marquez le moi là dans le chat je suis
curieux de regarder ça très très curieux
de regarder ça et en même temps je vais
essayer de voir si tout fonctionne bien
si le débit est bon le débit actuel
est on pe peutêtre modifier encore un
petit peu le débit alors
dites-moi c'est bon monsieur Greux
Pascal me dit j'espère que ça va un peu
mieux alors dites-moi où est-ce que vous
êtes où est-ce que vous vous situez dans
quel endroit êtes-vous on a Madagascar
pour
Franky il y a du mieux ça encore un peu
alors attendez peut-être modifier un peu
la latence la Suisse ahah
Strasbourg Strasbourg Strasbourg ajaxio
à Maurice yes alors tu dis bonjour à
Maurice tu l'Î Maurice je sais pas
bonjour Brive la gillarde pas très très
loin d'ici
euh tac tac tac région du sud on a La
Rochelle Israël coucou à tout le monde
en Israël légère sacade encore la Suisse
de
Poitiers proche de Paris salut les
Parisiens Bruxelles tiens j'étais avec
quelqu'un dans le train qui qui venait
de Belgique donc coucou à tous les à
tous nos amis belges je vois qu'il y a
le Québec Strasbourg France 7 la
Belgique vous êtes un peu partout ça
c'est chouette à voir Maroc euh Lyon
Djibouti très cool aussi euh Cholet
alors je pense que Cholet j'ai vu passer
tes messages tout à l'heure je regarde
le chat bien évidemment la Turquie
également salut à tous les Turcs qui
nous écoutent euh la Côte d'Ivoire
l'auverne adrien b on est dans on est
dans le même coin dans le même spot euh
chambéie la Corée waouh bienvenue coucou
il y a un petit décalage horaire
normalement la Réunion petit décalage un
petit peu aussi le Mali coucou à tous
les Maliens Brive B voilà il y a pas mal
de monde un peu partout voyez c'est
chouette à voir donc je suis très
content pour avoir ça dites-moi si ça
s'acade pas trop pour vous si ça va on
peut modifier encore le débit je vois
que marque le débit est supérieur je
vais modifier encore un peu mon débit
parce qu'on n pas là pour rigoler on
veut faire ça bien quand même on vaut en
profiter je vais modifier le débit et je
pense que là on devrait être normalement
pas trop mal je l'espère hop allez on va
regarder ce que ça raconte l'avand des
thtionville vous êtes vraiment de
partout vous êtes pas des Glob trotteur
mais vous êtes un peu partout ça c'est
cool le Gabon coucou
coucou à tous les gabonnais qui nous
regardent également je sais que vous
êtes êtes nombreux et nombreuses à
suivre la Normandie la région paka il y
a du monde de partout le Var j'adore le
Var j'ai passé tellement de temps étant
étant jeune c'est des gros souvenirs de
vacances Palestine un gros bisous aussi
à tous les PAL palestinien Lyon
l'Auvergne le doux Lille il y a du monde
tu as une communauté en VPN il y a du
monde il y a beaucoup de monde
effectivement de tous les côtés c'est
exactement ça et du
coup tu as qui comme smartphone t comme
smartphone tous les jours en ce moment
j'ai deux smartphones moi que j'utilise
tous les jours je vais avoir un iPhone
15 pro max avec ma coque monsieur Greux
et je vais avoir également un Galaxy S24
ultra que j'utilise tous les jours avec
moi il me quitte pas sont tous les jours
collés à moi Montréal également coucou
Washington DC ais coucou à tous ceux qui
sont bien évidemment sur le le continent
américain bon ça fait beaucoup de monde
est-ce que ça bug encore pour vous je
vois pour Christophe il marque ça bug un
petit peu est-ce que de votre côté ça va
ça fonctionne oui non quoi comment
marquez-moi ça je vais essayer de voir
s'il m'est possible de mon côté de faire
encore quelques ajustements ça je vais
pas y toucher sinon ça va être le bazar
room dites-moi si tout va bien je vais
regarder de mon côté
euh hop là comme ça en même temps je
vais faire les réglages en direct est-ce
que on a tac des trucs que j'aurais mal
fait éventuellement
euh hop là comme ça pas de souci ah
c'est mieux encore un petit lag euh
normalement ça à le faire alors je vous
raconte pas le bordel j'ai en fait juste
devant moi et j'ai honte le setup est
pas du tout optimisé vous êtes là c'est
la caméra est là j'ai un moniteur ici un
autre moniteur là sur lequel ben je vais
naviguer sur Internet sauf que il y a la
caméra devant donc c'est pas très
pratique et là j'ai le un autre moniteur
avec le le le le chat donc c'est quand
même bien mais il y a des trucs à revoir
du coup vous êtes juste devant moi et
vous me déranger pour regarder le mec
qui est très très bien organisé vous
avez vu ça je suis vraiment au top là
rien ne va plus c'est le bazar ça va le
faire ça va le faire ça va le faire je
regarde juste il y a deux trois trucs
que je peux venir modifier rapidement
histoire que on soit au top du top et
que ça aille bien pour tout le monde
parce que c'est quand même le but on va
se le dire on veut que tout le monde
soit bien pour venir visionner regarder
il y a un peu de monde donc là soyez les
bienvenu à tous ceux et à toutes celles
qui nous rejoignent bien évidemment je
regarde ce que j'ai de côté alors
attendez voilà je crois que j'ai les
infos je crois que en fait c'est ça je
vais venir diminuer encore un petit peu
ça et je pense que euh là on devrait
être pas dégueu quand même je pense
qu'on devrait être pas
dégueu allez je modifie encore un petit
peu tac tac tac bim bam boum pif paf
pouf et je pense que ça va être pas mal
normalement ça devrait être pas mal je
l'espère du moins sinon vous me marquez
he dans le chat he moi je suis là pour
lire vos AG on est là pour un live
interactif alors je vous explique le
principe en fait le le constat ça vient
de quoi ça vient que je me je reçois
beaucoup de messages euh alors on va
remonter un peu avant déjà il y a vous
l'avez remarqué probablement depuis le
mois de juin je fais une vidéo tous les
mois quel smartphone acheter au mois de
temps parce que les tarifs bougent parce
qu'il y a des nouveaux produits qui se
lancent tout le temps et je me suis dit
ça serait quand même cool de passer un
peu de temps à vous aider à des grossir
le terrain autant je fais des vidéos
j'en faisais beaucoup enfin un peu moins
aujourd'hui je faisais beaucoup de
vidéos pour vous présenter des des
nouveaux produits et vous dire ben tiens
il y a une vidéo sur ce produit-l il y a
une vidéo sur ce produit-là il y a une
vidéo sur ce produit-là et puis je me
disais en fait je me mets à votre place
et quand on cherche un produit des fois
c'est compliqué d'avoir une vision
d'ensemble parce qu'il y en a tellement
il y a vachement de produits il y a
vachement de smartphones j'arrête de
dire produit il y a beaucoup de
smartphones et du coup c'est compliqué
je me suis donc dit et et puis j'ai des
potes qui me l'ont dit on a beaucoup
discuté avec mes potes on discute voyez
vachement de tout ça et je me suis dit
et on s'est tous dit ensemble est-ce
qu'à un moment serait pas stratégique et
intelligent pour vous aider et vient de
faire une vidéo tous les mois pour vous
aider à dégrossir et avoir une vision
d'ensemble donc là j'ai commencé à
lancer au mois de juin ma première vidéo
quel smartphone acheter en juin 2023 ça
a continué juillet je l'ai fait je sais
pas fait en août je crois et après on a
attaqué en septembre donc là tous les
mois il y a une vidéo quel smartphone
acheter sauf que en réalité et bien
euh je je reçois encore vachement de
messages de personnes forcément chaque
cas est différent où on dit qu'est-ce
que je j'ai ça comme budget tiens j'ite
entre celui-là et celui-là qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire et c'est la limite du
système de venir faire une vidéo
c'està-dire que alors je peux répondre
en commentaire je le fais mais pas à
tout le monde il y a beaucoup de
messages j'en sois sur insta j'en sois
partout de tous les côté c'est l'enfer
non pas que je reçoive des messages mais
que je peux pas vous répondre de partout
donc je me suis dit tiens tous les mois
on va se faire un live et dans ce live
on va prendre du temps et je vais
répondre à vos questions voilà
excusez-moi ça bug plus pour moi tant
mieux batterfou ça va mieux vous voyez
comme quoi des fois modifiant les
paramètres on finit par y arriver donc
l'idée de ce live c'est de prendre du
temps pour discuter avec vous alors
comme on est un peu nombreux sur la
chaîne vous vous l'aurez sûrement vu euh
je me suis dit bon on on va faire le
premier live on l'ouvre pour tout le
monde et ensuite les Liv suivants ça
sera des lives réservés aux abonnés de
la chaîne donc pour l'instant sur ce
premier live on est là tous ensemble
peut-être que dans un peu plus tard dans
la dans dans dans le live je modifierai
les paramètres du chat pour que ce soit
que les abonnés qui puissent avoir accès
pour je puisse répondre à vos questions
parce que la le la problématique c'est
que il y a tellement de monde que je
c'est compliqué de répondre à tout le
monde et pas passer du temps sur chacun
individuel parce que si je vais répondre
à quelqu'un qui cherche un un un un
smartphone qui a besoin d'être aidé un
petit peu et ben c'est je peux pas
répondre à tout le monde en même temps
donc pour pouvoir passer un peu de temps
sur le chat et vous aider répondre
correctement j'ai décidé de de bloquer
entre guillemets bloquer aux abonnés
uniquement donc si vous souhaitez pour
les prochaines fois et même pour cette
fois-i pourquoi pas pour filer un coup
de main vous abonner bah écoutez vous
vous abonnez à la chaîne comme ça vous
aurez accès au prochain live mensuel
pour vous aider à venir choisir votre
smartphone et puis il y aura d'autres
Liv qu'on fera je sais pas de quelle
manière il y a encore plein de choses
qui sont à à mettre en place d'ailleurs
je sais pas si vous avez vu sur la
chaîne il y a plein de choses qui
évoluent des choses qui changent des
formats qui évoluent donc voilà il y a
plein de trucs à faire et donc voilà je
teste des choses j'essaye mais je pense
vraiment que ce format live il est
important parce que pour aller plus loin
dans le dans l'aide que je peux vous
apporter à venir choisir un smartphone
voilà voilà un peu l'idée voilà ce qu'il
en est je sais pas si c'est un un
concept qui vous botte j'imagine que si
vous êtes là tout de suite c'est que
c'est un concept qui vous botte un peu
euh n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous
en pensez bien évidemment dans les dans
les dans dans dans le chat dans les
commentaires bon dans le chat je les
regarde comme ça je vois vos petits
messages Maxime n mais coucou monsieur
Greux de la Belgique salut à tous les
Belges quel idée d'être aussi célèbre
aussi tu parles non mais en fait je
pense que tu vois l'idée de base je vois
ce que M je vois ce que mais c'est toi
batterfou qui met ça bfou 65 en fait le
le le le l'idée c'est de vous aider vous
accompagner dans votre vie numérique je
je reçois beaucoup de téléphones je vois
beaucoup de marques je parle avec plein
plein de fabricants et euh ça me permet
d'avoir une une expertise dans ce
domaine là donc si je peux la mettre à
profit et vous aider c'est avec grand
plaisir donc voilà je regarde un peu en
même temps vos messages qu'est-ce que
vous me dites euh bonjour alors on va
commencer à regarder bonjour ah ça c'est
une question qui m'intéresse enfin elle
m'intéresse tout mais c vous allez voir
elle va aider pas mal de monde bonjour
iPhone 12 Pro ou S23 et feu j'ai besoin
de conseil c'est la la question que nous
pose Mathieu Mathieu alors attends
est-ce que euh je peux épingler ton
message je vais épingler ton message
Mathieu pendant qu'on répond à ta
question et y a plein de fonctionnalités
on en profite he puis moi je découvre
des trucs parce que comme je fais des
lives de temps en temps mais pas
beaucoup donc ta question en fait pour
moi Mathieu
euh ce sont deux produits tellement
différents et et la vraie grosse
différence c'est pas tant le produit en
lui-même c'est l'os donc je me dirais
euh tu me parles d'un iPhone 12 Pro ou
d'un S23 fe est-ce que Mathieu tu peux
mettre dans le chat est-ce que tu as
déjà un produit autre que ce smartphone
Android ou ou ou Apple à savoir
un un produit écosystème un Mac est-ce
que tu as un Galaxy book est-ce que tu
as une une watch est-ce que tu as des
choses comme ça marque-le-moi dans le
marque-le- mooi pour que je je le vois
en même temps dans le dans le dans le
chat alors je regarde ton message
Mathieu je sais qu'il y a un petit
décalage entre le moment où moi je te
parle et le moment où tu vas pouvoir
répondre euh comme ça on va pouvoir
regarder ta question en direct en même
temps je regarde les autres messages
salut je vais craquer sur le rock Phone
8 très cool de rock Phone 8 carrément tu
peux y aller les yeux fermés
euh je vois d'autres messages on
regardera S23 ultra ou S24 plus euh
ça c'est c'est intéressant aussi mais je
qu' répondre d'abord à la question de
Mathieu parce que euh Mathieu es-tu là
Mathieu es-tu là es-tu dans le coin je
veux voir ton message Mathieu alors on y
va n pas d'autres messages de Mathieu
est-ce que Mathieu a disparu bon en fait
allez je vais essayer de répondre de
façon un peu générique souvent quand on
rentre on exite entre un iPhone ou un
Android et bien c'est tout simplement
que le choix va se faire sur l'os on a
deux très jolis produits entre d'un côté
l'iPhone 12 Pro même si c'est pas la
dernière génération Matthieu aouré j'ai
jamais eu d'Apple d'accord donc tu te
poses la question de venir switcher
directement sur un iPhone je comprends m
tu al en fait je t'explique le truc
c'est que si tu as jamais eu d'iPhone et
que tu as envie d'y aller est-ce que tu
as d'un côté tu as une tu as une montre
de Samsung euh une Galaxy watch quelle
qu'elle soit et bien forcément tu vas
plus pouvoir l'utiliser directement si
maintenant tu en as pas et que tu as
envie d'essayer ça peut être intéressant
iOS pour ceux qui connaissent iOS
fonctionne quand même relativement
différemment mais c'est vachement
appréciable et on s'y repère moi j'ai
j'ai deux smartphones voyez c'est
Android et iOS donc ça me va très bien
au quotidien il y a pas souci maintenant
à la question pure entre le matériel
entre un iPhone 12 Pro et un Galaxy S23
F fe moi j'aurais tendance à te dire va
sur le Galaxy S23 fe qui va quand même
être plus récent et qui ira je pense un
peu plus loin que ce que propose
aujourd'hui l'iPhone 12 Pro si
maintenant tu as envie de te laisser
tenter pour aller sur iOS et découvrir
iOS et aller voir explorer nouveaux
horizons je pense que ça vaut le coup et
que là-dessus pour moi il y a pas
d'arnaque il y a pas de problème donc
l'iPhone 12 Pro reste un très joli
smartphone efficace il a quand même
quelques générations il a quelques
années un peu où il a fait existe depuis
quelques années je seraai toi j' dirais
sur le plus récent Galaxy S23 fe
maintenant c'est toujours une question
de tarif voir à combien est-ce que tu
peux trouver un iPhone un iPhone 12 Pro
je Me' rems par contte combien que ça
coûte aujourd'hui faites voir attends
tac un iPhone 12
Pro combien ça coûte aujourd'hui un
iPhone 12 Pro j'en sais rien du tout je
fais iPhone 12 por qui sait même pas
écrire back market 411 cty deal 410 400
balles donc à 400 balles je peux
potentiellement me trouver un iPhone 12
Pro 400 entre 400 et 500 balles ça me
paraît être honnête là-dessus donc bon
moi moi je pense que tu peux moi j'irai
sur le se Galaxy S23 se après Vail que
Vail voir si tu veux si tu veux tenter
l'aventure alors attends je désépingle
ton message et je vais prendre une autre
question alors qu'avons-nous comme
message tiens Tibo qui nous met est-ce
qu'il y a mieux qu'un Galaxy S22 3 pour
euh 600 alors attends je vais épingler
ton message parce que si bouge je
pourrais pas le lire euh tac est-ce
qu'il y a mieux qu'un Galaxy S22 pardon
S22 ultra pour 670 €. euh moi je pense
que oui je pense que oui je pense que
pour 670 € en 2024 tu dois quand même
pouvoir trouver mieux alors attends je
vais regarder ce qu'on peut quand même
trouver qui sera intéressant
euh 600 so 70 € laisse-moi réfléchir
Galaxy S22 ultra il est intéressant il
est polyvalent le Space zoom on s'en
fond on va pas aller si loin faoto nu il
était pas dégueu quand même il
fonctionnait quand même pas mal ça
dépend ce que tu veux d'ailleurs combien
est-ce que ça vaut encore ce téléphone
aujourd'hui parce que ça ça bouge quand
même vachement tac regardez on va se
mettre là ça bouge vachement hop là je
m'y perd avec mes mes multiécran combien
ça vaut aujourd'hui un Galaxy S22 ultra
fais voir très curieux de savoir ce que
ça vaut ah ouais t trouve 600 balles
reconditionné back market toujours
pareil un peu la même chose bien
évidemment en fait et combien il est le
S23 ultra attends on va regarder en même
temps parce que ça peut être intéressant
aussi de voir un S23
ultra le S23 ultra je le préfère en fait
il y a un vrai gap déjà on va commencer
entre le S22 ultra et le S23 ultra c'est
le processeur exyos versus Snapdragon il
y a quand même une une différence de ce
côté-là
euh
en fait c'est compliqué si tu veux
d'arriver avec un smartphone haut de
gamme dans un budget à 670 balles c'est
toujours ça qui est un peu délicat après
moi ce que je te recommanderais très
honnêtement c'est ce qu'on voyait tout à
l'heure c'est d'aller sur un S23 fe je
t'en mets là S23 pas F gros tu dis
n'importe quoi c'est le pas fr c'est F
voilà c'est celui-là qui aujourd'hui sur
le site de Samsung combien il nous le
sorte Samsung combien vous nous le
sortez celui-là
euh alors attends parce qu'elle est
reprise laess ça donc faut toujours
faire un peu gaffe non je veux pas de
reprise à l'achat 699 moi aujourd'hui
j'irai plus là-dessus tu vois 699 €. euh
j'aurais pas la même polyvalence que je
vais avoir j'irai pas aussi loin que ce
que j'ai avec un S22 Fe au niveau du
zoom mais par contre j'ai un smartphone
qui est extrêmement polyvalent et ça
pour moi c'est quand même le truc le
plus important je sais pas si te mettre
la fichech j'apprends pas mes fiches
techniques par cœur parce que ça sert à
rien
euh attends qu'est-ce qu'il me [__] là
tac
euh on s'en fout du prix comparer la
taille les fonctionnalités clé ah voilà
on y va moi j'irai là-dessus très
honnêtement déjà tu as l'écran dynamic
amolet 2x qui est juste top et qui est
très bien et qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
sur tous les smartphones aujourd'hui
dans les haut de Games chez Samsung donc
là-dessus tu as pas de mauvaise surprise
bordel de merde mais comment ça se fait
que je TR ah voilà corningia glace on
s'en fout les fonctionnalités ça on s'en
fout zoom tuas un zoom optique x 3 bon x
30 numérique tuas pas besoin d'aller
bien bien plus loin moi je ferai ça très
honnêtement tu tu vois si j'avais 600
quelques balles à mettre au lieu d'aller
sur un S22 ultra en reconditionné j'irai
sur un S23 fe franchement franchement
c'est là-dessus que j'irai Tibao allez
next one les copains les amis je regarde
vos messages en même temps
euh Tam
Tam j'essaie de regarder en même temps
il y a beaucoup de monde donc je je
jeess de lire un peu en diagonale
l'iPhone 13 mini c'est bien en 2024 oui
pour moi tu peux encore aller sur un
iPhone 13 mini non pas parce que c'est
marqué iPhone 13 mais parce que c'est
mini avec le format est mini donc le
format mini pour moi il reste très canon
je vous mets en plein écran ça sera
quand même beaucoup mieux
euh bonjour monsieur Grun ou mais Kevin
alors attends je vais essayer t'épingler
parce que sinon le message va
disparaître euh Kevin je t'ai épinglé ou
pas ah je t'ai épinglé voilà tu es là
j'ai un samsung galaxy S23 ultra me
conseillees-tu de prendre le S24 ultra
en sachant que j'ai pas lu hop là voilà
en sachant que qu'il y aura bientôt des
mises à jour non Kevin il faut que tu
gardes ton smartphone je veux vraiment
c'est pas parce que je parle de tech et
c'est pas je dis pas que toi qui le dit
mais en fait c'est un truc est important
à à à dire conservez vos smartphones le
plus longtemps possible parce que il y a
bien évidemment plein de fonctionnalités
Galaxy ai du qu'on voit sur le S24 ultra
qui débarque sur le S23 ultra bien
évidemment on n'a pas la même puce mais
on a la génération d'avant qui est très
très très bien le S23 ultra était il est
d'ailleurs par là-bas un de mes coups de
cœur l'année dernière c'était mon
smartphone coup de cœur le S24 Ultra est
très cool mais garde ton smartphone
garde-le longtemps Samsung propose
pendant très longtemps des mises à jour
logiciel des mises à jour d'os de
sécurité donc il faut vraiment garder
son smartphone le plus longtemps
possible ton argent ton portefeuille te
dira merci et la planète te remerciera
également Kevin donc non ne change pas
vraiment ne change pas ça ne sert à rien
bon il y a peut-être des trucs que tu
auras pas mais globalement tu seras pas
frustré pour autant
euh alors attends tiens on a une
question intéressante là sur le gaming
et l'iPhone de dejin FPS l'iPhone 15 pro
Max est fait pour le gaming mais selon
toi est-ce que ça vaut un ROG ou un red
Magic hop là le bout du message s
supprimé que je le vois bien je suis
gamer de haut niveau latence tactile
refroidissement refroidissement
puissance moi je pense
que tu n'as pas la même expérience de
gaming sur un iPhone 15 pro max que tu
auras sur un un rock Phone 8 ou que tu
l'auras sur le dernier red Magic non pas
que tu manqueras de puissance tu
manquera pas de puissance c'estap dragon
8 Gen 3 ira très bien si tu mets en face
la puce A17 pro dans les deux cas ça
fonctionne bien et et tu auras pas de
problème tu as du R tracing
matériel je crois que c'est 17 pro c'est
matériel ou c'est logiciel je sais plus
duré tracing dans tous les cas mais les
l'expérience de gaming ça va bien
au-delà de la puissance de la
performance d'avoir un bel écran c'est
pour ça que moi je continue à aimer
vraiment ce que fait Asus là-dessus au
niveau de son rock phone parce que tu as
Armory create d'un point de vue Software
qui est quand même pas mal où tu peux
venir régler pas mal de choses de façon
assez finement enfin assez finement donc
ça me paraît pas mal tu as une fois de
plus les j'ai bouffé le oh [__] j'ai
bouffé le nom alors aidez-moi aidez-moi
dans le chat comment on appelle ça déjà
sur Asus parce que je me j'aime pas
perdre des mots des fois comme ça les
air trigger ça y est je l'IS les air
trigger qui te rajoutent des
fonctionnalités en plus tu as ton
ventilateur pour rafraîchir ton
smartphone tu as une prise jack qui est
pas mal si tu veux te connecter
directement donc pour moi autant je suis
d'accord un iPhone 15 pro max pour le
gaming pour faire tourner des jeux ça
fonctionne il y a aucun problème autant
pour moi si on va emmener l'expérience
plus loin en terme de gaming on va chez
ROG ROG Phone 8 Pro à mini a chez Red
Magic qui s également optimisé mais moi
aujourd'hui c'est quand même Asus qui me
plaît vraiment avec son son rockphone 8
Pro euh tu me conseilles quoi entre le
pixel 7a et alors attends c'est amori
Baptiste je te mets là haut pour te
regarder tu me conseilles quoi entre le
pixel 7a et le S23
fu alors je vais te montrer un truc je
sais pas si dans la dernière vidéo je
vous ai fait les le tarif du pixel 7a
avait vraiment baissé et ça c'était
super attends on est où là on va arrêter
là sur le S23 fe on va se mettre sur le
pixel
7 pixel
7a pourquoi j'ai fait ça je suis obligé
de décaler ma tête pour voir euh voilà
pixel 7a il est là pixel 7a regardons
pixel 7a si je veux l'acheter je suis à
509 balles 509 balles il était à combien
quand je vous ai fait la j'ai pas appris
par cœur une fois de plus
euh
les tarifs on remonté ou quoi j'avais
399 qu'est-ce qu'ils nous ont fait
Google ils ont remonté les tarifs c'est
moi qui fumé des pêtes ou pas non je
crois pas pixel 7a voilà et
699 versus 500 balles même si je suis
persuadé que le pixel 7a tu peux le
toucher moins cher euh 400 300 balles
bon back market il y a duû
reconditionner pour moi d'une question
juste de tarifs
j'irai sur le pixel 7a même si je trouve
que l'autre est quand même très très
cool mais le pixel 7a il y a le tarif à
un moment tu vois il y a vraiment le
truc quoi euh on a un message al
attendez je vais venir l'épingler
également comme ça je prendrai le temps
de le lire de si Ahed Si Ahmed prononcer
le H correctement bonsoir Monsieur Greux
est-ce qu'il y a des différences dans la
photo entre le S23 ultra et le S24 ultra
il y a forcément des différences déjà
parce que le trait
il y a une différence d'optique il y a
des choix optiques qui ont été fait qui
sont différents il y a une différence
pourquoi est-ce que Siri s'est déclenché
là on sait pas pourquoi il y a une
différence hop je sais pas pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai Siri qui se déclenche
sur mon je regrette je n'ai pas de
réponse à cela est-ce que je peux vous
aider pour autre chose je voudrais que
Siri s'en aille de mon mac merci au
revoir Siri il y a des différence bien
évidemment les capteurs évoluent les
choix sont pas les mêmes le processeur
n'est pas le même et ça ça compte aussi
pour énormément dans la dans dans la
dans la photographie après pour autant
la qualité que tu vas avoir entre un S23
ultra et S24 ultra même si il y a des
différences ça reste quand même des
excellents smartphones dans un cas comme
dans l'autre donc je dirais que si on
arrive à trouver un S23 ultra moins cher
ou si on en a un on le garde si on
arrive à en trouver un pas cher par
rapport au S24 ultra si maintenant on
veut vraiment le S24 ultra on va dessus
le S24 ultra sera un peu meilleur mais
il y a pas non plus une valise d'écart
c'est pas non plus une grosse zfle voilà
je fais une petite pause parce que j'ai
j'ai des petits des petits je teste une
nouvelle console là pour faire mon live
regardez c'est ça là pas une pub c'est
juste que ça me fait marrer c'est juste
pour ceux qui font des lives c'est la
petite rcter de de Rod et j'ai vu qu'il
y avait des effets sur la voie et ça
m'amuse de mettre des petits effets sur
la voix
attendez attendez attendez attendez
voilà là j'ai une voix qui fait un peu
peur c'est juste que ça me fait marrer
monstre
monstre pitchup donc là je peux vous
raconter une blague comme ça alors c'est
l'histoire de Toto c'est absolument
ridicule voilà ça me fait R et voilà
voilà il a il y a des effets aussi voilà
j'ai fini ma blague ok allez je reviens
avec vous bon c'est petite petite petite
parenthèse et puis des fois ça va je
vous parlerai comme ça mais je crois que
celui qui me fait le plus marrer ça le
le pitup alors les lapins HM ok ok allez
on continue
euh je regarde en même temps demain je
dois acheter allez tiens on va regarder
Pierro cari on épingle ton message et on
regarde ce que ça raconte là-haut demain
je dois acheter un nouveau Phone et
j'hésite beaucoup entre trois produits
dans mon budget le redmi note 13 pro
plus le pixel 7a le poco X6 pro
j'aimerais un tel équilibré photo jeu tu
oublies le poco déjà pour tout ce qui va
être je photo euh parce que là tu es
quand même dans deux mondes différents
entre d'un côté poco et de l'autre côté
le pixel 7a
euh ok moi je
euh j'aurais tendance dans ce que tu me
dis un truc équilibré entre photo et
gaming à t'envoyé sur le redmi note 13
pro plus c'est là-d su géré parce que tu
vas avoir un poco X6 pro qui va être
orienté gaming mais qui est en photo bon
un pixel 7a qui va être top photo mais
qui en terme de perf c'est une tensor
bon redmi note 13 pro plus je crois que
j'ai la bte à côté bouge pas je
reviensends c'est alors
[Musique]
attend fait tout vous
expliquer
j'ai la boîte du 13 pro et le pro plus
j'ai elle est dans ma valise j'ai une
valoche ça c'est ma valise voyez et dans
ma valise que j'ai pas encore déballé
parce que je rentre tout juste j'étais à
la capital voir nos amis parisiens et le
13 pro plus est dans ma valise avec sa
boîte
merde il y a des trucs que je peux pas
vous montrer làdedans FA
gaffe
voilà c'est ça TR pro
plus c'est mignon hein pour moi c'est
cool comme
smartphone d'ailleurs si vous l'avez pas
je la remets dans sa boîte quand je le
déplace mais ah il est là il est ouvert
il est
configuré
voilà je trouve joli moi ce
smartphone hop après je trouve que
vraiment les les noms les noms ilêes pas
quoi 13 Pro 13 pro plus à la fin tu sais
plus quoi correspond à quoi voilà tu
vois il est sympa moi je l'aime bien ce
téléphone
attends hop là
voilà je trouve que l'écran est sympa
sur le 13 pro plus très légèrement
incurvé sur le côté très très légèrement
incurvé sur le côté tu vois il est assez
lumineux bon je pense que en plein
soleil en été regardez quand même comme
ça là voyez dès que je pousse la
luminosité à fond ça devra faire le taf
hein ça va faire le taf il est pas mal
au niveau de la photo voyez al déjà
j'aime bien le design à l'arrière il a
du mal il y a ma tête il fait plus point
dessus voilà j'aime bien le design je
trouve pas mal
euh après on Lesch médiiathèque en terme
de performance on est sur un demmen City
c'est un demmen city combien déjà je me
rappelle même plus c'est un il marque
tout làdessus une fois de plus voilà ça
qu'ils aiment bien chez Xiaomi ils
aiment bien montrer les SPE donc dès que
tu ouvres tu as des specs de partout ils
aiment bien t'en mettre plein la gueule
euh c'est le demmen City 7200 ultra bon
ok moi je pense que là-dessus tu as un
bon compromis qui va être honnête et
correct en photo tu feras moins de les
photos seront moins belles que ce que tu
auras sur un pixel 7a mais euh pour le
gaming ça sera mieux que sur un pixel 7a
et les photos seront meilleures que sur
un poco X6 pro donc moi je vais
là-dessus sans aucun problème voilà
j'espère avoir répondu à ta question je
regarde en même
temps vos messages on va regarder le
message de Sam Sam
Sam
Sam bonsoir Monsieur Greux entre un oppo
x 5 Pro un Google pixel 7 Pro a prix
égal
a prix égal lequel prendrais-tu
personnellement je prendrai
personnellement un oppo findix 5
parce que c'était mon smartphone coup de
cœur de l'année 2022 parce que j'adore
le traitement d'images qu'à ce
smartphone je le trouve tout autant
performant je le trouve efficace et la
douceur qu'on a au niveau des cliché au
niveau des photos pour moi c'est
vraiment un point très fort et j'adore
ce smartphone et je te conseille d'aller
sureli-là le le le pixel 7 Pro est bien
mais on n pas ce cette cette ambiance
que peuvent donner les les photos et
pour moi le F 5 Pro il est il est au top
là-dessus quoi au top là-dessus très
clairement euh salut monsieur Greux
plutôt iPhone 15 pro max ou S24
ultra iOS Android tu la différence en
fait je vais te dire je prends ta
question parce que je t'expliquis en
fait c'est pour moi le truc qui est
vraiment intéressant en ce moment Mac 83
Var bisous à tous ceux qui vont sont du
Var moi j'ai passé toutes mes vacances
quand j'étais petit à La Favière plage
du plage de Bor et mimosa à côté du
lavendou donc pour ceux qui connaissent
et pour ceux qui sont de là-bas je vous
embrasse parce que j'ai une affection
particulière pour cette cette région et
pour ce
coin je vous explique en fait
aujourd'hui Apple bien évidemment va
avoir à de l'a dans ses smartphones elle
l'a voilà on va arrêter Galaxy ai ça
marche bien c'est bien mais de l'IA il y
en a partout Samsung a quand même fait
un gros pas en avant en intégrant de l'a
plus plus plus et en le faisant bien
donc c'est quand même bien fait c'est
malin il y a de belles fonctionnalités
et ils font ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui
d'un d'un constructeur de smartphone à
savoir vous mettre plein de
fonctionnalités il y a les mettre en
avant et ça pour moi c'est extrêmement
pertinent ça c'est le premier truc
aujourd'hui quand vous avez un iPhone
moi j'ai mon iphone 15 pro max là que
j'utilise aussi tous les jours et bien
mon iphone 15 pro max il a de Lia à
l'intérieur mais il a pas de
fonctionnalité aussi poussée que ce que
propose aujourd'hui mon galaxy S24 ultra
c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui je pense que le Galaxy S24
ultra et le smartphone quand on veut de
l'a il y en a pas d'autres qui qui qui
feront autant pixel a plein d'
énormément d' c'est je pense le numéro 2
que je mettrai derrière quoi que des
fois ils peuvent se tenir mais pour moi
le le l'iPhone il est tout de suite pas
au même niveau d'IA j'attends de voir ce
que va nous annoncer Apple à la WWDC au
mois de juin 2024 parce qu'il est
évident que leur nouvelle os va pas
faire rigoler et que il va y avoir plein
de fonctionnalités il a qui vont être
intégrées et ça ça va être super cool
donc aujourd'hui euh si tu
veux si tu t'en fous de l'IA tu et que
tu veux un iPhone iOS iPhone 15 pro max
mais si tu cherches un smartphone et que
tu veux de Lia et que tu veux des trucs
vraiment cool les fonctionnalités
vraiment sympa moi j'irai sur le Galaxy
Ione 4 ultra tout en sachant qu'il y a
des fois des choses qui sont pas encore
accepté tu vois moi quand je l'ai testé
par exemple le S24 ultra et que j'étais
je vais le faire avec cette petite voix
là et que j'ai été appelé des gens et
ben les gens ils m'ont raccroché au nez
et ça c'était vexant parce qu'en fait je
les appelais avec mon téléphone et j'
disais oui bonjour voilà je voudrais
réserver un restaurant pour tel truc ou
je voudrais des informations sur le menu
j'étais aux États-Unis à ce moment-là et
là les gens ils avaient une voix qui
leur disaiit en en anglais hein bonjour
Un logiciel j'ai du mal à me concentrer
avec cette voix il y a un logiciel
euh c'est absolument ridiculeêre comme
ça trop peur il y a un logiciel en fait
qui va traduire qui va aider à traduire
et qui après donnerit une voix qui
apportait la la la version de ce que moi
je disais mais en anglais et et les gens
raccrochaient parce que les gens ne sont
pas prês tout de suite sont pas encore
assez informés donc ça va continuer
enfin ça va prendre de plus en plus et
ça deviendra plus pertinent mais je
trouvais ça quand même marrant quoi
voilà voilà voilà
euh allez je vais regarder un petit peu
il y a plein de messages vous êtes là
nombreux nombreuses c'est la folie folle
et alors je le redis juste he pour ceux
qui étaient pas là dès le départ parce
qu'il y en a forcément qui étaient pas
là dès le départ et c'est normal parce
qu'il y a un moment on a autre chose à
[__] je vous explique ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est que hop là
attendez je vais me mettre là je fais
des choses en même temps que je vous
parle he je regarde en même temps mes
trucs euh ce que je vous disais c'est
que je fais cette vidéo pour vous aider
et
vous vous
accompagner dans vos choix et que euh je
vais je vais les amis euh faire cette
vidéo mais pour les les abonnés de la
chaîne alors les membres de la chaîne
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a des fois
entre twitch et et Youtube c'est pas le
même vocabulaire c'est pas les gens qui
sont abonnés c'est les gens qui sont
membres de la chaîne aujourd'hui être
membre de la chaîne c'est un abonnement
je crois ça coûte 5 balles par mois ou 3
balles je sais plus enfin ça coûte
peut-être TR balles je sais plus trop et
euh et parce que en fait comme vous le
revoyez tout de suite tout de suite vous
êtes 300 personnes connectées en même
temps et je vous remercie énormément
mais je peux pas prendre les questions
de tout le monde parce que c'est
compliqué de de faire le de faire le tri
donc là où il y a mon œ qui se pose paf
je prends la question et si elle me
semble être bonne pour tout le monde
aider le maximum de personnes donc on se
fera des Liv le le mois prochain qui
sera réservé uniquement pas aux abonnés
j'utilise bien les bons termes mais aux
membres de la chaîne c'estes membres
qu'on dit je crois attendez que je dise
pas de bêtises euh ce sont les les
membres voilà ce sont les membres membre
donc si vous voulez pour le mois
prochain membre comme ça vous serez
onbardé dans la partie voilà mes petits
lapins d'amour
euh je si je le dis comme ça voilà mes
petits lapins d'amour c'est absolument
ridicule allez on continue avec les
messages
euh Nino nous dit salut monsieur Grux
comment vas-tu iPhone 15 14 pro ou S23
ultra c'est toujours là en fait c'est la
même chose que je dis tout à l'heure en
fait ça va dépendre si tu veux iOS ou
Android mais les deux sont très très
bien tu prends le le maximum de la
génération précédente les deux vont très
très bien bonjour monsieur gre faut-il
quitter un poco F3 pour un poco X6 pro
j'aurais tendance à dire oui si ton poco
F3 commence à vieillir un peu qui
commence à ramer mais sinon garde-le
tant qu'il va bien salut monsieur gr
première fois que je te vois en live ça
fait plaisir salut ratonio et ben c'est
la première fois que je lis ton message
dans Live et je suis aussi très heureux
excusez-moi je bois un coup de flotte
parce que il y a un
moment ça ça sèche j'ai la gorge qui
sèche et c'est
dur est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu
quelqu'un boire avec une voix pitcher
c'est horrible regardez je vous fais
écouter
ah c'est super
alors c'est tellement ridicule ça me
fait rire je suis désolé sais pas
pourquoi ça me fait tellement rire alors
attendezatts je regarde j'ai beau mettre
trois écrans de tous les côtés j'ai
l'impression qu'il en faudra encore un
4e c'est n'importe quoi hop BIM vous
savez que j'ai une camé ça c'est la
prière caméra j'ai une deuxè caméra qui
est juste là salut toi ça c'est mon
Sony meilleure qualité Sony FX3 très
bien et là j'ai l'insta 360 linkon pas
par la colorimétrie pas la même j'ai pas
d'effet B j'ai pas de Bet que là j'ai un
bet c'est magnifique vous voyez derrière
mes mousses que je dois installer au
plafond de ma pièce qui résonne on
l'entend dans les vidéos ça résonne mous
installé et que malheureusement j'ai
toujours pas fait
donc il va falloir il va falloir parce
que là ça ne va pas il mousse installé
et puis il y a du bordel de tous les
côtés un peu le bordel chez moi mais bon
alors les petits amis on va revenir sur
vos messages
ah nous avons une photo de Tom d'API une
photo je une photo mec il est il
n'importe quoi je vais essayer de
t'épingler Tom je t'épingle Tom Tom tu
es épinglé Tom tu es angla alors Tom
quii de l' du oneplus 12 vas-tu faire un
vlog dessus et bien en fait pour tout te
dire Tom no news good news one plus no
news good news et j'adorerais avoir des
news j'adorerais qu'il me parle
j'adorerais qu'il me comme à la bonne
époque one plus à une époque one plus on
on on s'entendait bien et puis tu
m'envoyais des des messages alors je
crois que bon il y a eu quand même pas
mal des des équipes épurées il y a une
équipe a quelques années où ils ont tout
épuré ils ont je crois dégagé les gens
enfin voilà il y a plus d'équipe en
France ils ont remonté a une autre
équipe je crois que la personne qui s'en
occupé enfin avec qui moi j'avis en
contact à outot euh aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il reste une personne mais je sais
même plus où elle est je crois que c'est
Victor Victor je t'embrasse mais j'ai
aucune nouvelle donc en fait moi l'idée
c'est de vous parler de produits que
j'ai que j'ai vu que je connais je parle
avec les marques comme ça s'il y a des
questions bah ils peuvent me répondre là
aujourd'hui one plus ils sont de mon
côté en ce qui concerne aus abonnés
absents donc je ne peux pas vous
recommander onepl je peux pas vous en
parler parce que c'est pas uniquement
sur une fiche technique que j'auraai des
choses pertinentes à vous raconter donc
bon là-dessus euh non malheureusement
Natl me dit salut ça va ça va et toi
euh bonjour avez-vous des infos sur le
Honor Magic 6 pro et le Google pixel 9
pro malheureusement je ne vis pas encore
dans le futur mais oui ça viendra très
bientôt euh bien évidemment ment
monsieur Greux si je quitte mon iphone
15 pour un pixel 8 Pro c'est bien non
l'iPhone 15 il est très récent si tu
veux alors je vais te poser la question
inox pourquoi est-ce que tu veux quitter
ton iPhone 15 marque-le moi dans le dans
le dans le chat est-ce que tu veux
quitter parce que tu en as marre d'Apple
et que tu dis
parce que l'iPhone 15 il est quand même
sorti au MO de septembre l'année
dernière donc il est très récent ça fait
moins d'un an que tu as un iPhone 15 et
déjà tu veux changer pourquoi ça ça
m'intéresse pourquoi est-ce que tu veux
quitter ton iPhone potentiellement
quitter iOS pour Android allez je je
regarde le chat euh en guettant ton euh
ton message allez je veux ta réponse là
on attend alors il y a y a une fois de
plus le petit décalage entre le moment
où moi je suis en train de parler le
chat qui est ralenti autant vous dire
qu'on a quand même quelques secondes
d'écart entre vous et moi mais ça ne
change rien en même temps je regarder il
va falloir faire des efforts de mémoire
Aurélien 1 absolument absolument
absolument d'ailleurs pour faire des
efforts de mémoire regardez ce que j'ai
acheté vous fout de ma gueule
regardez je me suis acheté un
bouquin je me suis acheté un bouquin que
j'ai reçu aujourd'hui
j'ai acheté ça
ça connaissance générale c'est pas une
pub je dis une fois de plus parce que
bon et j'ai
vu pour travailler sa mémoire améliorez
votre mémoire et enrichissezla de
connaissance sur l'histoire la politique
l'économie la science la religion la
littérature et bien plus encore donc
j'ai acheté ce bouquin que je vais lire
savez quoi je vais le lire et je vais le
lire avec un stabilo comme ça je vais
stabiloter et je vais prendre des notes
comme quand je bossais à la fac c'est
cool hein donc j'a bien j'aime bien
faire c exerci là voilà ça m'amuse alors
je reviens cherche le message d'inox
inox inox inox m'as-tu répondu il y a
des messages est-ce que je l'ai loupé ou
pas je ne vois pas de message ah inox
pour changer d'interface trop longtemps
sur Apple je les trouve bien voilà donc
c'est iOS tu vois c'est exactement ça en
fait merci d'avoir préciser c'est ce que
je pensais c'est-à-dire qu'en fait la
question c'est iOS j'ai envie de
nouvelles aventures j'ai envie de
quitter ma meuf ou mon mec peu importe
et d'aller ailleurs et d'aller sur
Android et ben tu as raison parce que
des fois c'est bien aller voir ce qui se
passe ailleurs pas quand tu es en couple
attention donc je pense que c'est
intéressant maintenant c'est le truc qui
est un peu un peu dommage c'est que
l'iPhone 15 il est très récent je
continue à pousser pour dire que quand
tu as un smartphone il faut le garder le
plus longtemps possible pour éviter
justement et bien de de de de la
surconsommation je pousse vraiment pas à
ça donc garde-le le plus longtemps
possible mais le pixel 8 Pro est un très
joli smartphone et le jour où tu devras
changer peut-être faudra-t-il aller sur
un pixel 9 pro ou un pixel 10 pro à ce
moment-là si le nom est toujours le même
parce que voilà mais oui le pixel 8 Pro
est un très très cool smartphone mais
c'est c'est c'est c'est dommage de
laisser tomber un iPhone 15 qui quand
même tout après tu fais ce que tu veux
c'est c'est à toi c'est c'est son c'est
ton budget
euh tu connais unenix d'umidiji non j'ai
pas regardé ce qu'il faisait régul
dernièrement humidiji tu m'cheter un si
tu veux euh
humidiji
hum est-ce que j'écris bien ça fait un
petit moment que jeis je pas aller voir
ce qu'il faisait eux et on va aller
regarder ensemble tiens allez c'est il
part j'ai cliqué ça serait bien que ça
parte allez on avance c'est parti ouais
alors lequel tu me disais c'était le
attends je retourner voir dans le chat
infinix infinix il dit qu'il sait pas du
tout hein
infinix ça fait très longtemps que j'ai
pas regardé ce qu'il faisit eu très très
très très
longtemps en audio
ouais bon ils ont des
tablette watch je connais pas c'est
c'est quoi ce produit parce que ça me
parle pas du tout humidig infinix je
sais pas du tout fais
voirid
infix what
that what
that ZTE connector je vois des trucs
attendez what
that tu me parles bien de ça ça me dit
rien et et j'ai l'impression que ça dit
rien Google non plus donc si ça dit rien
Google ça dit rien Google
quoi il dit il dit que il dit que ça lui
parle pas du tout ça vous parle vous
connaissez vous dans le chat ça
marquez-le moi je sais pas si ça vous
parle attends où est-ce où est ma souris
ah il estan mulo
euh c'est le quel téléphone gaming entre
euh Adrien nous dit le Red Magic 9 pro
et le rock Phone 8 Pro avec des argument
s'il te plaît Adrien tu étais pas tout à
l'heure je pourquoi attends je reprends
je continue à penser que aujourd'hui
l'expérience qui moi personnellement me
plaît le plus en gaming c'est
l'expérience d'Asus Armory create d'un
point de vue logiciel tous les réglages
que je peux avoir derrière c'est là où
je j'aime en tout cas passer le plus de
temps c'est le smartphone qui et c'est
très personnel me plaît le plus je
trouve que Asus ça a amélioré un peu sa
copie en photo mais il y a encore des
choses à revoir c'est pas parfait mais
pour moi c'est vraiment ce cette notion
d'écosystème alors bien évidemment tu
vas avir aussi le même système Air
trigger il est là-bas le le Red Magic
attends fais voir hop il est pas chargé
il est pas chargé il est
où qu'est-ce que j'en ai
fait je l' rangé
je sais plus où je l'ai
rangé c'est un peu le bordel bon il est
pas là mais il est rangé quelque part
j'ai dû le mettre dans les placards
c'est c'est vraiment l'expérience
purement logicielle qui me PL matériel
parce que snapdagon 8 Gen 3 ça fait pas
rigoler mais d'un côté comme de l'eau
donc là-dessus il y a aucun problème
mais une fois de plus moi ce qui me
plaît c'est vraiment Armor crate c'est
le fait d'avoir le petit ventilateur
qu'on peut brancher derrière c'est
d'avoir une prise jack c'est d'avoir de
l'usbc en dessous de l'avoir sur le côté
de l'avoir de tous les co les
accessoires et tous les accessoires
qu'on a aujourd'hui sur le rock phone en
fait un smartphone très à part regardez
ce que j'ai reçu jeai pas encore
déblastterisé c'est le Nubia c'est le
Z60 ultra Z60 ultra d'ailleurs on peut
prendre 30 secondes et regarder ça
ensemble est-ce que je vais réussir à
ouvrir ce truc j'espère que oui sinon
j'ai derrière moi mon pote le ciseau et
mon pote le ciseau il est toujours là
pour moin de service ben ouais faut dire
qu'on passe tellement de temps ensemble
alors faites voir bon s
alors
hop puis après on va reprendre vos
questions la marque Tecno je connais
ouais exactement Ismaël moi tu sais
Ismaël j'ai une histoire à te raconter
qui est vachement intéressante sur la
marque techno à savoir que l'année
dernière au MWC j'ai vu la marque techno
je suis allé les voir et j'ai fait une
petite vidéo
sur ce qui ressemble au Z
fold 4 à l'époque et je me dis [__]
les mecs ils ont vraiment pompé pompé de
chez pompé ils sont vraiment allés
jusqu'au bout de l'histoire j'ai fait
une petite vidéo je l'ai publié et tout
je trouvais ça assez dingue et en fait
quand je l'ai posté j'ai vu et je suis
très heureux d'avoir eu tous les retours
sur Facebook c'est un short
Facebook TikTok je crois Instagram des
retours de la communauté en Afrique qui
connaissaient et qui disaent c'est
génial parce qu'en fait ça ça arrive
chez nous et ça c'est génial et moi j'ai
trouvé ça ol je connaissais pas cette
marque et maintenant je la connais et ça
pour moi c'est vraiment vraiment cool
alors attendez pendant ce temps je en
train d'ouvrir le nouveau Nubia qui va
être très bientôt ouvert parce
que parce que je
déteste rid le numéro de
Sage regarde ça que ça c'est pas ça ça
pas de la gueule j'adore le look de ce
smartphone jeallais m'amuser avec je
vais aller le tester je l'ai pas du tout
allumé encore bah vous voyez je le
déballe hein donc il est lourd il est
super lourd c'est un vrai pavé le bordel
c'est un vrai pavé mais regardez-moi ce
truc quoi franchement c'est pas un truc
très atypique on a pas de genre de chose
de trucs comme ça trop aujourd'hui hein
donc ça c'est cool ça ça va m'amuser
pendant un petit moment
Nubia hop donc ça euh je vous en reparle
dans la prochaine vidéo je sais pas si
je vais faire une vidéo sur ce
smartphone peut-être pas j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que le mois prochain je vous dirai si
c'est un smartphone à venir acheter ou
pas et s'il vaut le coup ou pas ou pas
hop hop voilà je
reposerien voilà j'espère que je t'ai
répondu et que ça t'aura
éclairé Darknet merci pour le TIPS de 2
€ tiens je te mets un petit cœur d'amour
je devrais changer ou pas j'ai un OPO
find x alors attends il est où ton ton
message euh Darknet tu nous as mis quoi
d'autre attends attends est-ce que j'ai
loupé je t'ai répondu tout à l'heure pas
je t'ai parlé tout à l'heure Darknet
[Musique]
attends je remonte le chat en même temps
que je vous
parle
Darknet je devrais changer de téléphone
ou pas actuellement je possède un oppo
find 5 qui est incroyable en photo le
find 5 est bien le find 5 Pro est encore
meilleur tu veux al att- tu avais mis le
message avant hop
[Musique]
euh attends attends attends attends
attends attends j'essaie de retrouver
ton
message je devrais changer de téléphone
ou pas Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim
Tim je remonte dans l'histoire du chat
je revais je vais plus haut
[Musique]
euh t t t
h c'est là où vous voyez c'est pas
toujours évident de
hop est-ce que j'ai vu ton message ou
pas je remonte je remonte je remonte je
remonte je remonte je remonte je remonte
j'ai l'impression de faire de l'escalade
à mon SIO faudrait pas que je tombe
serait con je me ferai mal au dos alors
euh on y est on retourne j'ai pas vu
d'autres messages effectivement tu as un
FX 5 qui est un excellent smartphone de
oppo j'avais bien aimé ce qu'ils avaient
fait c'était juste avant qu'il partte de
chez nous hein il sont jamais sorti le
fix 6 en France F 6 pro jamais
malheureusement c'est
dommage je l'ai pas vu ton autre
message je te laisse me remettre un
message dans
le dans le
chat non je crois que je monté tout en
haut du chat et je l'ai pas vu ton
message je vais attendsz je un il en
même
temps je regarde je regarde je regarde
je
regarde je regarde remarque-moi ton
repose-moi ta question euh
Darknet hop je regarde en même temps pas
Tim Tim
Tim Darknet Darknet
Darknet si ta question c'est juste j'ai
un oppo find x 5 est-ce que je dois le
changer ou pas moi je pense que tant
qu'il va bien il faut le garder hein le
plus longtemps possible parce qu'il faut
garder ses smartphones assez longtemps
et ça pour moi ça reste une fois de plus
un truc extrêmement important si
maintenant il commence à battre de l'ail
j'espère pas parce qu'il est quand même
relativement récent et bien why not mais
si les photos continuent à être très
bonnes et toi tu aimes les photos parce
que ça reste le point quand même le plus
important tu me marques je devrais
changer ou pas et que tu mettais juste
avant j'aime les les photos sur ce ce
smartphone c'est tant qu'il fait le taf
tant que la batterie tient tant que il
répond à tes questions et tant qu'il
permet effectivement de faire ce que tu
as à faire avec ton smartphone tous les
jours à savoir tes réseaux tes mails
faire des recherches et compagnie et
bien il faut le garder bien évidemment
s'il continue à s'il commence pardon
excuse-moi à montrer des signes de
faiblesse à ce moment-là tu peux le
changer à ce moment-là et uniquement à
ce moment-là parce que je le dis et je
le repense vraiment une fois de plus
gardez vos smartphones le plus longtemps
possible ne changez pas tout le temps ne
changeer pas trop je ne dis pas que
c'est ton cas je ne dis pas que c'est ce
que tu fais mais il faut vraiment faire
extrêmement attention à ça et n'hésite
pas à me poser à remettre ta question
dans le chat parce que j'ai remonté et
voilà oppo va revenir en France n dit
Xavier j'ai bien évidemment vu passer
des trucs comme ça mais pour l'instant
euh pour l'instant tant que c'est pas
fait tu vois il dit toujours beaucoup de
choses moi tout ce que je peux dire
c'est que l'équipe qui existit de oppo
elle n'existe plus hein elle est
complètement disloquée donc ça veut dire
que si oppo revient en France il va
falloir qu'il une autre équipe qui se
monte il va falloir enfin voilà c'est
peut-être hein ils sont capables de le
faire serait pas les premiers en tout
cas a priori d'un deal qui aurait été
trouvé avec Nokia bon on verra ça euh on
a un message de Philippe qui est membre
depuis 21 mois merci Philippe d'être
membre depuis 20 an mois puis je le dis
aux autres aussi n'oubliez pas là je
vous le disais ce premier live on le
fait tous ensemble comme ça ça c'est
ouvert à tous mais le prochain il sera
réservé uniquement aux membres de la
chaîne euh pour qu'on puisse prendre un
petit peu le temps de de discuter entre
nous ça sera je pense plus simple plus
simple pour réussir à identifier vos
questions voilà donc nésitez pas aller
jeter un coup d'œil sur Youtube je sais
pas si vous avez un lien sous vos yeux
mais en tout cas vous pouvez y aller
docteur Greux bonjour c'est pour une
c'est pour une opération j'espère que
vous allez bien très bien
présenter le Samsung Android
A55
A55 il m'intéresse énormément je vous
remercie alors moi je pense Philippe que
le A55 n'est pas sorti je pense
Philippe que euh qu'est-ce que c'est que
ça
Philippe Philippe Philippe on va se
mettre en navigateur comme ça mon
Philippe je reviens là attends voilà
comme ça chez
Samsung nous avons la gamme a dans les
smartphones nous avons la gamme a qui
est ici et le A55 et le A35 ne sont pas
sortis nous avons toujours le A54 et
nous avons toujours le
A34 qui sont présents ici par contre
sont sortis il faut que je baisse la
tête sur le côté là voilà le A25 le
A15 en fait ils font ça pour en garder
un peu sous le pied normalement il
devrait être annoncé et sortir le A55 et
le A35 je pense au printemps au
printemps donc on en reparlera bien
évidemment sont des smartphones qui
cartonnent et on en reparlera
aujourd'hui ce qui est sorti en
équivalent du A55 et bien c'est ce que
je te montrais tout à l'heure c'est
celui-à hop hop je me mélange pas les
pinceaux c'est ça ça c'est le A55 de
chez Xiaomi c'est c'est son équivalent
en fait c'est son équivalent mais
aujourd'hui le A55 malheureusement
Philippe n'est pas arrivé encore mais je
suis sur le coup tu penses bien que de
celui-là dès qu'il sort paf je me jette
dessus comme ça comme un loup sur des
agneaux et j'aime tellement les
smartphones de Samsung
euh allez on va prendre la question de
Blaze bonsoir salut Blaze je cherche un
téléphone compact euh quels sont vos
conseils attends je vais t'épingler
là-haut parce que comme ça je pourrais
te voir hop là te voilà épingl je
cherche un téléphone compact quels sont
vos conseils pas de pliable j'ai compris
penses-tu qu'il va y avoir un téléphone
un téléphone attends bouge pas un
téléphone un nouveau téléphone compact
en 2024
oui oui oui oui oui moi je pense que
celui à voir alors moi quand on parle de
compact aujourd'hui euh sur
euh les les iPhon c'est les mini bon il
y a pas de mini depuis de générations
mais bon ce que je te conseille à
contrario par contre c'est d'aller
là-dessus et ça c'est le zenfone et ça
c'est Asus zenfone 10 le zenfone 10 il
est très cool alors il reste quand même
un tarif un peu coquin un peu moins de
700 balles parce qu'il a un tout petit
format tu vois c'est ce format là et ce
format là il est cool parce que tu es à
- 6 pouces tu es à 5,9 ou un truc comme
ça je veux pas te dire de bêtises euh je
sais plus mais c'est un petit écran
petit format très compact 5,9 tu vois il
tient il tient il tient en main il tient
très bien en main il est très bien et
c'est vraiment ce que je te conseille je
pense que Asus sortira bientôt un zphone
11 tous les constructeurs avancent tous
tous il y a juste Apple je crois qu'il
bougeent pas mais ils avancent tous leur
date de lancement donc si tu cherches du
compact aujourd'hui sur un
smartphone Android zenphone c'est sinon
ce que tu peux faire c'est
aller Galaxy S c'est pas du compact mais
c'est un peu plus petit c'est le S24
mais il est quand même grand tu vois BIM
viens par là mon
lapin il est quand même grand mais ça va
être le plus compact de de de ces
smartphones là voilà voilà mais pour moi
compact zenfone très clairement c'est
pour moi vraiment ce que je vais donner
tu veux du compact tu vas aller dessus
hop
alors question
suivante dragon mon qui m' tient qui m'
tuas raison tu m'as tu m'as mis tu m'as
directement tagué j'ai actuellement le
Honor Magic 5 Pro ça vaut le coup de
changer si oui lequel je cherche le top
du top si tu aimes le top du top garde
le Honor Magic 5 Pro qui aujourd'hui
reste un excellent smartphone tu as
plein de super techno que mettent au
nord à l'intérieur de l'antiin pour les
yeux tu as le rythme circadien enfin il
est vraiment vraiment bien tu as un
appareil photo un blog photo qui est
absolument incroyable l'année dernière
si'il avait pas eu le S23
ultra j'aurais clairement pris en coup
de cœur dans l'année mon Magic 5 Pro qui
est vraiment super smartphone garde-le
parce que vraiment c'est un produit que
je recommande plus plus plus plus plus
euh je regarde brer qui met g longtemps
je suis sur redmi note 5 Pro depuis 7
ans il est temps de changer ah alors
attends bouge pas
épingl il est temps de changer et quand
il est temps de changer il est temps de
changer il est temps de changer note 1
5G
ou note 12 Pro 5G
ah quel est le meilleur choix ou autre
pas cher chez bug donc tu as un forfait
big et tu veux renouveler chez bug ce
que je comprends
absolument
euh quel est ton tarif ton budget on va
regarder combien il valent j'ai pas le
j'ai pas les les chiffres exacts en tête
mais si je regarde combien ça coûte
aujourd'hui
un RMI on se parle d'un redmi not 13
hein quand tu marques ou al tu mets
bouge
pas je vais jeis du la beatbox
hop je pense qu'on parle du redmi note
13 on va aller chez Xiaomi et oui redmi
note 13 229
€ tu me parles de chez Big Telecom mes
copains de
bug BG
Télécom
alors B Télécom
OK
euh mais après ça dépend des forfaits ça
va dépendre du forfait ça va dépend moi
je pense que à ta question il faut lu
apporter une réponse à ta question
est-ce que je vais sur le redmi note 13
5G ou le redmi note 12 Pro 5G j'aurais
toujours tendance à t'envoyer sur la
dernière génération
euh parce que même si on te met tu vois
par exemple là un triple capteur photo
108 mégapixel de tois à moi tu vas juste
avoir le capteur principal qui va faire
le taf par
contre ce qui reste important dans des
smartphones plutôt situés dans l'entrée
de gamme ça va être les les mises à jour
ça va être ton OS ça va être ta ta ta
puce combien de temps tu vas pouvoir la
garder jusqu'où tu vas pouvoir l'emmener
donc moi je serai toi j'irai sur un
redmi note 13 5G qui sera ici le
smartphone je dirais le plus le plus
récent parce que quand tu vas sur un
smartphone très haut de gamme tu as
quand même une une puce qui te permet
d'aller plus loin
euh oui oui je vois ton message redmi
note 13 5G ouais j'ai compris 12 Pro non
mais moi je pense vraiment que j'irai
sur le note 13
5G parce que tu te dis qu'avec le note
12 Pro 5G tu en auras un peu plus tu en
auras un peu plus tu en auras pas un peu
plus tu en auras effectivement un peu
plus mais ça va pas non plus te mettre
une valise dans la tronche déà quand on
commence à te marquer un processeur
Snapdragon puissant et qu'on tu met pas
la référence dis-toi que tu es pas dans
les plus puissants mais ce qui est
normal après ce qui va nous intéresser
ici tu vois sur le note 13 l'appareil
photo le 108 probablement mais une fois
de plus tu auras pas des capteurs de fou
parce que te laisse pas avir il te
metett tous des très grands chiffres
attention mais le capteur de 108 il y a
108 et 108 il y a capteur et capteur
donc bon ça fera le taf mais voilà moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est que tu vas
avoir une techno AMOLED ça c'est quand
même pas mal 120 Hz plutôt convenable
bonne résolution
euh de la recharge 33 W c'est convenable
une grosse batterie c'est toujours ce
qu'on recherche dans cette gamme de prix
et puis après tout le reste bon il te
raconte il te raconte un peu la chanson
quoi un ultra grand angle de 8 mégapixel
voilà ça serera des souvenirs mais voilà
la macro 2 mégapixel toutbl ce qui nous
intéresse ici c'est le 108 le 108 et
c'est vraiment ce qui nous intéresse le
reste c'est pas ouf zoom sans perdre x 3
tu vas venir chercher dans ton capteur
tu vois quand tu as un zoom x 3 en fait
tu as pas de téléobjectif ici donc c'est
en fait un zoom numérique dans ton cap
108 mégapixel ce qui va se passer c'est
que il va venir croper dans l'image donc
ici tu vas pas dégrader énormément la
qualité et ça restera convenable mais
tout le reste macro et compagnie regarde
ça là c'est c'est pour moi c'est ni fait
ni à faire le rendu les
contours c'est c'est pas c'est pas
terrible par contre voilà tu en as pour
ton argent et c'est un smartphone qui
est très honnête et vraiment le truc qui
m'intéresse toujours énormément ici sur
ces produits là sont les écrans parce
que tu as quand même un écran AMOLED qui
est cool bon après il balance les
chiffres et ça bon luminosité maximale
1800 Nitz ouais si tu veux ouais
peut-être en plein soleil mais voilà
pour moi tu as un truc qui est bien qui
sera honnête qui sera efficace et qui
sera même pour le gaming taux
d'chantillonnage tactique 240 Hz pour le
gaming ça va ça marche bien il y a aucun
problème donc voilà ça c'est quand même
cool maintenant si tu vas regarder en
face le redmi note 12 Pro on va regarder
pro 5G voilà qui est là le pro 5G qui
est là
alors alors là il te parle déjà de la
caméra l'mx 766 qui est une un capteur
qui est qui est très bien chez Sony qui
est voilà tu auras de la recharge un peu
plus rapide mais après l'écran ça sera
la même chose tau de rafraîchissement ça
sera la même chose tu l'auras
probablement un tarrive un peu plus
maîtrisé mais ton bloc de charge de
toute façon falloir venir CIS qu'il il
te le livrait pasè je sais plus s'il le
livre avec ou pas mais mis à part avoir
un capteur qui sera un peu meilleur même
taille de batterie même techno d'écran
même résolution la charge plus rapide
globalement tu t'en fous un peu méiathek
versus Qualcom ici bon voilà il a
quasiment même combat un capteur photo
qui sera un peu meilleur mais bon voilà
si tu touches au même prix ces deux
smartphones moi j'irai quand même sur le
note 13 une fois de plus pour des
questions de génération je pense que
c'est ce qui va être intéressant ici
aujourd'hui sur les questions de
génération sur les questions de misise à
jour les choses comme ça dans le temps
parce que tu y gagneras avec des mises à
jour un peu plus qui iront un peu plus
loin dans le temps que ce que tu n'auras
pas avec un smartphone qui a déjà 1 an
même s reste convenable si tu touches le
le redmi note 12 Pro moins cher ouais
sinon non sinon non
euh saruto bonsoir Monsieur Greux je
suis sur Samsung Galaxy A32 et
j'aimerais passer sur un iPhone hop je
t'épingle làhaut j'aimerais passer sur
un iPhone est-ce une bonne idée de
passer d'Android iOS du coup je suis
très intégré par les appareil iOS oui
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr il y
a aucun problème tu peux totalement
passer sur un un smartphone iOS en
venant d'Android au début tu vas être un
peu lar en attends comment ça marche tu
t fais extrêmement rapidement il y a
aucun problème c'est très très cool le
A32
ok je comprends qu'avec le temps on a un
peu envie de changer alors après a 32 tu
étais quand même dans du milieu de gamme
entré milieu de gamme plutôt milieu de
gamme début du milieu de gamme si tu
passes sur un iPhone tu vas tout de
suite faire un St en terme de de
performance et de tarif même si tu vas
acheter du reconditionné je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les iPhones il faut aller
le plus bas où on peut descendre sont
les iPhone 12 les iPhone 11 étaient
sympas mais ça commence quand même un
peu vraiment à vieillir iPhone 13 c'est
très très bien il y a pas de souci
là-dessus ça dépend du tarif donc oui
bien évidemment on peut passer d'Android
iOS sans aucun problème et
réciproquement dans les deux cas ça ira
très très très bien euh brazer qui me
dit merci beaucoup tu as pris le temps
pour un petit truc pour un excuse-moi
pour un truc petit prix c'est cool je
viens du note 5 Pro ça sera une
révolution ça va vraiment de changer la
vie très clairement parce que là ton
smartphone et c'est bien parce que tu l'
emmené plus loin donc c'est cool très
très cool Aurélien ben tiens on va
regarder Aurélien parce que entre
Aurélien on va se faire une
fleur salut Aurélien et oui je suis
Aurélien moi aussi tiens alors attends
je bois un coup parce que bon mine de
rien faut boire un coup l'eau c'est
l'eau c'est important dans dans 20 ans
il y en aura plus Jean-Claude on
t'aime sidrate pas assez quand même moi
j'ai une copine qui nous a fait des
calcul Ren là c'est Dr pas ass de l'eau
mes amis de l'eau alors que nous dit
Aurel Aurélien Aurélien moi j'ai une
question pour toi moi qui m'appelle
Aurélien on m'appelle souvent Adrien et
ça m'énerve non pas que j'ai quelque
chose contre le prénom Adrien mais quand
on t'appelle tout le temps Adrien il
moment dire mais arrêtez je ne m'appelle
pas Adrien respectez-moi nonom de nom ok
quel smart
pour remplacer un onepl 6t j'ai beaucoup
aimé le onepl 6 à l'époque avec le même
esprit de onepl à l'époque j'ai vu no
sing phone 2 mais je trouve le prix
élevé oui c'est vrai noing phone 2 est
un peu élevé à côté de ça l'esprit one
plus de l'époque n'existe plus nulle
part tu as effectivement noing et je
suis d'accord avec toi Carl P qui est
un ancien de de de onepl Akis aussi il y
a pas mal de mecs qui étaient chez onepl
qui sont partis et qui sont chez nosing
aujourd'hui donc noing il y a
effectivement cette culture qui avait
avant chez onepl très peu de produits
mais des produits très cool je suis
d'accord que le phone 2 il est cher mais
en fait le phone 2 il est cher parce
qu'en fait tu en as vraiment déjà tuas
des produits tu as des matériaux chers à
l'intérieur on va aller voir noing
fun nothinging
fun BIM moi c'est un coup de cœur si 629
€ versus 729 € juste avant ça reste
quand même un smartphone qui a un
Snapdragon
8 plus Gen 1 qui reste très efficace tu
as quand même un écran AMOLED ltpo 6,7
pouces la photo c'est pas mal même si
c'est pas le meilleur tu as la glyf
interface tu as noing OS 2.0 qui
franchement est très très cool tu as
quelque chose de très à part très très
très atypique et moi j'adore vraiment ce
produit et je le dis mais sans aucun
problème j'adore ce produit je trouve
très joli très bien fait très efficace
le boulot qu' fait onepl ici il est
magnifique ça reste donc aujourd'hui un
smartphone voyez même au niveau de
l'expérience logiciel ça reste un
smartphone très atypique très efficace
et si on veut pas un smartphone fait
comme les autres pour moi on peut y
aller je suis d'accord qu'il est un peu
cher est-ce qu'on peut le trouver à
moins de 629 ça c'est truc intéressant
euh noing non pas no
est-ce que je peux le
trouver par opérateur ah ils sont
rentrés chez c'est marrant cool c'est
vachement bien 629 dy
629 c'est la même chose que chez noing
directement moi je le prendrai par noing
directement je regarde après c'est les
copains qui en parlent etci je dans
shopping
non pareil dararty là j'ai un j'en ai un
là qui est blanc à 586 alors ça reste un
beau budget quand même à moins que ce
soit du la marketplace ouais c'est de la
marketplace pay d'expédition l'Irlande
vendeur européen moi c'est toujours tu
te dis c'est ton smartphone il a un
problème et qu'il faut le renvoyer
derrière ça fait chier quoi tu vois moi
je le prendrai chez je comprends
Aurélien c'est un peu plus cher mais ça
reste quand même un produit qui est
super cool donc moi ouais euh si tu veux
dans l'esprit oneplus de l'époque
nothinging clairement
euh si tu as répondu à ma question ou
pas Aurélien sur Adrien j'en ai marre
qu'on m'appelle Adrien m'appelez pas
Adrien dans le chat je vous je vous
banne tous
euh quel smartphone ta Budak nous dit
salut à toi euh quel smartphone pour
remplacer le S20 fe aux alentours de 500
balles ah j'aime bien quand on me donne
des défis
ok alors on veut remplacer un S20 fe aux
alentours de 500 W voà ce qu'il faut
faire on prend la feuille de Monsieur
heureux dans lequelle on a toutes les
notes et on va regarder 500 balles et en
même temps
ouais S20 F feu S20 F feu moi ce que
j'aurais tendance à te dire tout de
suite franc de ber de tois à moi j'irai
directement
sur euh
euh bouge pas je suis en train d'arriver
dessus
voilà voilà moi je vais là-dessus bingo
banco pixel 7a 509 balles 509 balles je
suis 9 € au dessus de ton budget mais
par contre j'ai un truc très très bien
en photo polyvalent très bel écran euh
tu m'aurais dit je veux vraiment faire
du gaming à mort je te dirais je suis
pas sûr mais par contre tu vas avoir
plein de trucs super avec de Lia la
traduction en temps réel la gomme
magique le C le ça bref très très très
joli smartphone 6,1 pou c'est pas
l'écran le plus grand mais bon il est
quand même super bien euh voilà très
très bien moi vraiment j'adore en photo
il est magnifique et vraiment c'est un
produit que je recommande là-dessus les
yeux fermés alors après on peut aussi
aller chez mon copain Samsung parce que
chez Samsung euh on a euh sur la gamme a
on en en parlait tout à
l'heure sur la gamme a on y arrive sur
la gamme a nous avons nous avons nous
avons nous avons même s'il va être
remplacé le Galaxy A54 5G 449 balles
très très cool aussi ce que j'aime bien
sur ce produit c'est attends on regarder
laffich tech tu vas
voir on a un peu moins de 500 balles
pour le coup tu vas avoir ton écran de
6,4 pouces ça c'est quand même très très
bien 120 Hz parfait capteur principal de
50 qui vraiment fait le taf bon IP 67 ok
l'autonomie bon je crois que c'est du
5000 mamph la batterie si je dis pas de
bêtises
euh macro ça on s'en fout un peu l'ultra
grand angle il fait le taf he il est
bien il y a pas de souci là-dessus c'est
un smartphone qui est très polyvalent et
qui est très très bien après je t'aurais
bien dit il y a le S23 fe mais il est
quand même au-dessus des 500 balles et
là tout de suite ça va te coûter plus
cher et à un moment c'est pas dans le
budge que tu m'as annoncé euh j'ai dit
qu'il était à combien ce Galaxy S23 fe
pas longtemps le S23 F le S23 F fe le
S23 F 600 tu 699 c'est quand même plus
cher c'est quand même plus cher encore
le S23 il est quand même à 800 ball non
pixel 7a moi j'irai làdessus vraiment
voilà pixel 7a j'espère que ça te
plaira je suis là je suis là je m'y perd
entre tous mes écrans Jamel qui salut
salut gre salut Jamel coucou à
toi hop retirer le message
tac tac tac perso je viens de passer
attends salut tout le monde Devil nous
met ça salut salut mon perso je viens de
passer de mon oppo F X3 néo à mon
premier iPhone et un 15 pro max12 que du
bonheur ça do changer un peu l'histoire
effectivement nous avons une autre
question salut monsieur Greux je pense à
lâer mon pixel 6 pro avec la rom line os
est-ce que c'est une bonne décision
merci à
vous moi je le ferai pas nécessairement
si tu es un peu aventurier tu peux
t'amuser mais moi j'irai pas trop
là-dessus
euh bonsoir Monsieur grenous dit Gaetan
salut à toi actuellement j'ai un
Galaxy S10 plus qui commence à vieillir
je songe à le remplacer par une nouvelle
génération S24 ultra je pense que
l'évolu est plus visible que du
S23 ultra vers le S24 ultra et c'est
évident que en partant dans S10 plus et
si tu vas tout de suite là-dessus tu vas
voyager dans le temps mais ça sera une
très jolie découverte bien évidemment
moi le S10 plus j'avais bien aimé je
trouvais que c'est un bon téléphone ce
très bien à l'époque maintenant c'est ça
ça a vraiment évolué donc bon tu vas te
retrouver avec un truc très cool si tu
peux te permettre d'aller au S24 ultra
euh très très joli produit tu peux y
aller
euh bonsoir Monsieur Greux Xavier Nant
salut les nanté je suis vos vidéos
conseil depuis pas mal de temps vous
avez l'air assez speed sur vos vidéos là
tout calme c'est marrant le contraste en
fait Xavier je je peux pas toujours
crier pendant une heure et speed pendant
1 heure là ça fait quoi ça fait 1 heure
1 heure combien qu'on est en live
presque 1 he et dem si je suis speed
pareil pendant 1 heure et dem là ça va
être hyper dur en fait c'est souvent les
gens quand on se rendcte ils me disent
ah en fait il est pas si P que ça en
fait la différence elle est là
c'està-dire que quand je vais faire une
vidéo j'en sais rien moi tiens je on va
faire un exemple je va faire une démo là
j'ai le Nubia le S le Z60 ultra si je
commence ma vidéo en faisant bonjour à
tous aujourd'hui on va se parler du
Nubia le Z60 ultra j'aime bien il y a du
rouge c'est sympa tu vois il manque un
truc salut aujourd'hui on se parle de ça
c'est le Nubia le Z60 ultra et le Z60
ultra il arrache tu vois l'énergie c'est
pas la même je suis obligé de la porter
un cran plus haut après ça fait partie
de ma nature mais ça ça qui crée la
dynamique et qui crée le truc voà je
ferai comme ça coucou les petits lapins
on se parle du Z60 ultra de nubiab et là
voilà ça sera encore plus déconnant on
pourrait essayer j'ai peur
qu'effectivement ça saoule tout le monde
mais il faut là tu vois il faut la
dynamique parce que j'ai un exemple une
fois j'étais en train de de de faire je
rentrer dans voyage de presse on était à
Barcelone je crois et puis moi je suis
avec ma caméra dans dans l'aéroport paf
paf paf paf je vais là je vais de tous
les côtés et puis j'avais deux potes euh
qui eux je vais les voir et je leur
parle et et eux ils me parlent
normalement et moi je mets à parler
alors et là effectivement quand tu me
regardes en train de tourner tu dis
waouh c'est un excité les deux ils sont
normaux quand tu regardes la vidéo tu as
l'impression que moi je suis sur un un
truc dynamique et que eux deux ils sont
mou donc tu as besoin de porter
l'énergie sur une vidéo que là sur un
live je peux pas le porter de la même
manière parce que sinon euh un quart
d'heure après je suis par terre voilà
euh Alain bonjour monsieur Greux bon tu
ne veux pas répondre j'ai pas vu ton
message Alain désolé tant pis bonsoir tu
es
vénéralin j'ai acheté un Honor magxis
Lite suite à votre vidéo à Las Vegas
est-il un bon achat ouais c'est très
cool moi je pense que c'est la dernière
gamme qui est très bien chez chez Honor
qui est efficace ils ont une techno
d'écran qui est plus résistant ils
améliorent par rapport au au Magic 5
Lite qui était déjà pas mal l'année
dernière et qui est aussi un bon
smartphone donc tu peux y et Alain c'est
pas que je veux pas te répondre en fait
si tu veux c'est que il y a vachement de
messages et que je dois prendre un peu
un peu au pif quoi là où mes yeux
s'arrêtent parce qu'il y a il y a quand
même quelques messages et et je peux pas
je dois passer un peu de temps quand je
réponds à un message regarder voilà n
Chelsea Marty McFly ah oui tu crois
vraiment que la vendeuse de chez Dary
m'avait conseillé tu répond quelqu'un ok
autant pour moi j'ai pas suiv votre
conversation vous vous avez raison vous
raison échangez entre vous aussi il faut
pouvoir enrichir tout ça euh Jérémy nous
dit bonsoir Monsieur Greux je veux
passer dans zflip 4 à1 S24 ultra ou un
15 pro max un iPhone bien évidemment je
vais mettre ton message tout en haut
parce que le chat bouge et je vois plus
rien hop je bois un coup entre-temps si
je veux survivre à cette soirée de
folie alors attends je vais retourner à
ton message on vaer ça
ensemble
hop alors je reviens à ton message
lequel choisir car j'étais déçu de la
photo sur le zflip 4 dommage car le
reste est excellent alors effectivement
le zflip 4 en fait Samsung on
s'attendrait que sur des produits Z flip
on ait la même exigence que la gamme S
mais c'est pas le cas ils sont très bien
très bon mais ils vont pas aussi loin si
tu veux aller le plus loin en photo S24
ultra ou 15 pro max tu sais quoi dans
j'ai tourné une vidéo qui est en cours
de montage où je compare le Galaxy S24
ultra l'iPhone 15 pro max et le pixel 8
Pro si tu as quelques jours devant toi
regarde ma vidéo tu vas voir qu'en fait
c'est pas c'est pas très évident là où
le S24 ultra éclate les autres c'est sur
la photo de nuit mais il les éclate
vraiment vraiment vraiment sur les
photos de jour c'est pas très évident je
trouve que le le pixel 8 Pro mais tu
m'en parles pas il est un peu en
dessous mais l'iPhone 15 pro max il tire
quand même vachement son l'épingle du
jeu par contre le Galaxy S24 Ultra est
beaucoup plus polyvalent
parce que comme tu as un zoom optique x
3 et un x 5 x 2 x 5 non FO je sais plus
jamais avec eux j'ai pas marqué
là-dessus euh bref donc du coup tu peux
aller jusqu'à un X 10 sans dégrader ta
qualité sans aucun problème jusqu'au FO
désolé x 25 c'est très très bien et et
tu vas beaucoup plus loin en fait euh
maintenant ce qui va départager au-delà
de la photo si tu as pas besoin de venir
zoomer autant une fois de plus ça va
être l'os iOS Android si tu es déjà
habitué tu as déjà toute ta
configuration qui est faite sur un un
Galaxy reste sur un Galaxy fais un
transfert avec Smart switch et fais un
transfert de de de téléphone à l'autre
gardes ta configuration c'est facile
c'est pratique c'est sympa moi c'est ce
que je feraai en tout cas à ta place S24
ultra j'adore réellement ce téléphone il
y a aucun problème
là-dessus le bonsoir d'Alger salut wad à
toi
[Musique]
euh je cherche un téléphone pour faire
du vloguer et de belles photos attends
attends et de belles photos attends on
va se mettre là j'épingle big Locker
c'est ton moment à toi big Locker
welcome big Locker welcome big
loer je cherche un téléphone ce que je
te disais tout à l'heure pour faire du
vloguer de belles photos je dispose d'un
budget de 800 balles que me
conseilles-tu je te
conseille je te conseille un
iPhone en vidéo c'est les meilleurs en
photo il y a du très bon partout en
vidéo aujourd'hui pour moi Apple ils
sont encore devant les autres très très
très bon très très très très très très
bon pour venir vloguer pour avoir un
truc qui marche bien alors après il y en
a aut qui marche très bien soyons clair
de vous à moi les galaxies sont très
très bons également mais il y a un petit
cûp de reviens-y avec les iPhones budget
de 800 balles euh budget de 800
balles budget de 800
balles coucou toi
regardez nous allons aller bien
évidemment sur les iPhones découvrir
tous les iPhone et ben oui il y a un
moment il faut y aller il faut il faut
mettre les mains dans le camboui iPhone
13 combien tu coûtes j'ime bien ce petit
bleu voilà moi j'irai tu me dis 800
balles j'irai ça iPhone 13 128 alors
attention iPhone 13 tu as pas de
téléobjectif donc si tu veux vraiment de
belles photo peut-être qu'il faut aller
sur un 13 pro tu dois pouvoir en trouver
des 13 pro à des tarifs cool je ferai ça
peut-être euh
attends iPhone 13 pro combien ça se
trouve ça
aujourd'hui hop attends je t'en metets
là tu vois je trouve des trucs à
589 569 mois je pense que c'est à peu
près ce qu'il faut faire en fait je
pense que c'est à peu près ce qu'il faut
faire moi je ferai ça à ta place j'irai
sur un iPhone pour mes vidéos big Locker
si tu veux un truc un peu vlogué un peu
sympa très polyvalent qui est un peu bon
partout et et mauvais nulle part c'est
ce que je ferai en tout cas the
fantastic gamer je cherche un tel entre
600 et 900 balles et ma principale
option est l'autonomie le reste on va
dire que c'est secondaire tu me
conseilles quoi hop attends je t'enets
là-haut je t'épingle comme ça j'épingle
beaucoup de monde ce soir je suis un
épingleur fou euh 600 900 balles tu as
de la marge il quand même il y a un peu
de monde dans cette gamme de prix
l'autonomie
l'autonomie tu me conseilles quoi comme
marque un un pixel moi j'aime bien car
j'aime bien le style ou autre alors si
tu aimes bien le style des pixels on
peut carrément regarder effectivement
les pixels parce que si tu vas sur les
pixels tu as pas de mauvaise surprise
alors effectivement tu me dis 500 900
balles moi j'ai moins cher le pixel 7a
mais maintenant si tu as un peu plus on
peut aller voir du côté du pixel 8 tu
vois même le pixel même le pixel 8 Pro
tu vois là tu es à 800 balles tu es au
milieu de ton budget en fait sur le
pixel 8 tu as pas de
téléobjectif si maintenant tu veux jouer
vraiment la polyvalence avec une plus
grosse batterie puisque l'autonomie
c'est un truc important pour
toi il est cher 1099 ah merde on est
au-dessus he et ouais
non et bien moi je te dirai le pixel 8
alors tu vois
vraiment prês tu as pixel 7 Pro qui
était quand même pas mal du tout
hein 749 on a un truc pas mal là je
crois qu'on touche un truc là
749 c'était quand même un un bon
téléphone
749 pour moi tu es pas arnaqué là-dessus
tu as un truc très très bien je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec moi moi je pense
qu'on peut aller là-dessus euh si tu
aimes les pixels sans problème une fois
de plus c'est pas là où tu AA la
performance brute chez chez Google mais
par contre c'est très très très très
honnête là-dessus et vraiment on peut y
aller à mon sens je suis d'accord avec
moi
euh un téléphone pour le gaming à 500
balles nous dit Deadpool Ruby 333 alors
moi ce que je ferai quand j'ai un budget
comme ça je t'envoie chez les copains de
poco parce qu'ils ont vraiment orienté
gaming ils ont mis beaucoup de per un
tarif intéressant par contre là où c'est
un peu moins bon c'est la photo c'est un
peu le parent
pauvre série F tu peux aller voir du
côté du F5 tu m'as dit combien but je
sais plus j'ai pas je t'ai pas épinglé
pour le coup c'est une connerie que j'ai
fait euh 449 sur le
pro le F5 tu es un peu moins cher
fatalement 369 va acheter un œil chez
poco les photos c'est pas ce qu'il y a
de mieux mais par contre pour tout le
reste c'est quand même très très bien
bonsoir que vaut le S24 plus il est très
bien le S24 plus tu peux y aller Renault
me dit hello monsieur Grux salut à toi
super présentation merci beaucoup top
j'adore moi j'adore ton message bien
j'ai un Asus zphone 5 le 10 vaut-il le
coup je recherche je cherche Samsung A54
S23 S24 pixel merci à toi c'est
effectivement très large ta question
Renault moi ce que je te dis c'est que
le zenphone 10 c'est un smartphone que
j'adore il est performant il a un petit
format faut aimer le petit format il tu
as une expérience logicielle qui est
très bonne et qui marche très très très
bien là-dessus donc il y a aucun
problème donc pour moi là-dessus tu peux
y aller les yeux fermés et tu auras
aucune déception euh si maintenant euh
tu es pas sur de ton truc et que tu veux
aller voir
ailleurs ça dépend de ton budget tu vois
parce que tu me parles du A54 tu es à
moins de 500 balles tu me parles du S24
tu tu te rapproches des 1000 balles
c'est pas la même histoire Google pixel
c'est pareil ça dépend si c'est un 7a ou
pas moi je pense que le zphone 10 il
reste quand même un tarif un peu plus
élevé si tu veux du un peu moins cher tu
parles de pixel de set on on a beaucoup
parlé ce soir ça un très très joli
smartphone
après un peu un entre deux qui est
intéressant c'est le S23 F dont on
parlait un peu plus tôt dans le dans le
live qui est aussi un très bon rapport
qualité prix que personnellement je peux
te recommander tu peux y aller quoi euh
bonsoir Monsieur actuellement j'ai un
P30 Lite effectivement qui commence à
être vieux tu crois que mon Huawei
pourrait tenir encore combien de temps
il a plus de mise à jour mais il
fonctionne encore assez bien très
honnêtement Sacha c'est compliqué de
venir prdire ça s'il fonctionne encore
assez bien je te conseillerai de le
garder parce que bon une fois de plus
moi je suis pour qu'on garde nos
smartphones d'autant en plus que tu es
chez Huawei avec de très belles
finitions et tu as les services Google
ce qui n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
l'équivalent je te dirais d'aller chez
Honor si tu voulez à peu près la même un
équivalent euh tant qu'il fonctionne
garde-le garde-le tant que tant qu'il te
va bien et puis on peut en reparler
éventuellement dans un prochain un
prochain live d'ailleurs je vous le dis
une fois de plus je le redis ce live là
est ouvert à tout le monde le prochain
live on le fera uniquement avec les
membres de la de la chaîne donc euh si
vous souhaitez je perd ma souris allez
là ma petite souris si vous souhaitez
faire partie de la prochaine aventure
n'hésitez pas à rejoindre à devenir
membre de la chaîne comme ça on fera la
prochaine aventure ensemble mes petits
lapins et merci à Marien et à agès qui
nous ont rejoint il y a aussi Roméo qui
est devenu membre il y a pas très
longtemps merci à Roméo coucou à toi
vous êtes nombreux nombreux ça vient
c'est cool c'est chouette euh alors
attendez monsieur Greux est-ce que tu as
une voiture suréquipée en terme de haute
technologie mais absolument pas tu vas
te moquer de moi parce que j'ai pas de
voiture on a une voiture à la maison et
c'est la voiture de ma femme moi je suis
motard j'ai une Ducati mais qui n'est
absolument pas équipé en techno de ce
côté-là je suis pas très je suis pas
très bon je suis pas très bon
euh
l'empereec qui me dit hello bonsoir tu
es le meilleur tu m'as tu m'as guide
guidé dans mes achats la bise bah écoute
je t'en prie merci bonne surprise ton
live je savais pas que tu en faisais
bonne continuation de temps en temps tu
vois on va se faire tous les mois et
puis on va refaire des Liv parce que
j'aime bien l'exercice du live c'est le
moment où on est entre nous j'aime
passer du temps avec vous j'aime passer
ce moment de discussion pour moi c'est
un truc très important donc vous voyez
ça me plaît euh allez on se dit quoi là
il est
21h39 on se dit qu'on rest jusqu'à 22h
et puis euh parce qu'après je vais plus
avoir de voix et
oui je sais pas comment font les mecs
qui qui stream pendant des heures comme
ça et qui peuvent parler pendant des
heures je je à chaque fois je perds ma
voix du coup comme ça ça
c monsieur gre tu penses quoi du wi
viewmax reconditionné car j'ai un
collègue qui en posè
un je pense que c'est un peu vieux
maintenant tu
vois moi aujourd'hui j'iraai plus trop
chez Wiko en même reconditionné je pense
qu'il y a autre chose à trouver mieux
les
tarifs j'hésite entre un Adrien dit
entre un S22 plus un S22 ultra un iPhone
13 pro max tu me conseilles quoi niveau
photo vidéo surtout vidéo iPhone 13 pro
max photo
euh moi j'irai sur le 13 pro max tu vois
le S22 ultra était très bien le S22
plus bien aussi mais je pense que le le
13 pro Max va Leser surclasser j'ai un
Huawei Nova 9 sans Google et pépite ça
fonctionne sur pas bien super bien bravo
Jason très cool tu as raison tant qu'on
a pas on n pas tous besoin ou envie des
services Google gueule et heureusement
donc dès lors qu'on trouve son bonheur
et que ça nous convient ça va très très
bien
euh pas huawe mais Huawei i know you
right mais voilà j'aime bien dire Huawei
moi ça me rend heureux euh attendez où
est-ce que j'en suis bonjour ça bougé
j'ai perdu tout le monde
euh un téléphone de bonne qualité qui
coûte 700 balles nous dit calad àa il y
en a beaucoup à 700 balles honnêtement
c'est 700 balles tu es quand même dans
des dans du haut de gamme he donc tu vas
trouver plein de très jolis téléphon ça
dépend ce que tu veux iOS Android 700
balles 700 balles euh 700 balles je
réfléchis à ce que je pourrais
te j'ai mes notes et ouais j'ai mes
notes pixel 8 est-ce qu'il attends j'ai
pas regardé tout à l'heure esté de pixel
8 tout à l'heure j'avais un tarif là
à 699 est-ce qu'il est remonté auou pas
ce téléphone j'ai même pas fait gaffe
tout à
l'heure faites voir ah ouais il a
remonté c'est là ça change tout le temps
ces tarifs quand je vous dis de voir un
tarif vraiment il faut y rester parce
que les tarifs changent changent change
etchange hop là voilà donc non euh 700
balles 700
balles il y a plein de trucs hein moi je
pense que aujourd'hui il y a une marque
qui est rassure et qui a un peu une
valeur
j'irai là-dessus S23 F tu vois 699 € 128
Go de stockage l'écran est top l'audio
fonctionne bien les photos sont très
très bien pas de problème pas de
mauvaise surprise tu es pas déçu et tu
as un truc qui est très très bien moi ce
que c'est ça que je ferais
euh hop
là
excusez-moi bonsoir Monsieur gr on m'a
proposé trois téléphones le choix est
difficile stp aide moi je vais t'aider
je suis là pour toi regarde e on y va je
te mets tout en haut je t'épingle
épinglé
alors là le choix difficile aide-moi
là-dessus là-dessus tu me
dis batterie de
qualité attends là dessus sur plus
qualité batterie automatique ça veut
dire quoi automatique fonctionnalité
Huawei P30 pro pixel 6 pro S10
plus
euh trois téléphones qu'on propose le
P30 pro moi le P30 pro je l'ai beaucoup
aimé mais il a quand même bien vieilli
aujourd'hui enfin tu vois entre les
trois téléphones dont tu me parles celui
sur lequel j'irai c'est le pixel 6 pro
les S10 plus et le P30 pro je trouve
plus vieux que ton pixel 6 pro donc pour
moi je dirais sur le pixel 6 pro
là-dessus c'est vraiment le choix que je
ferais en tout cas
[Musique]
euh
question de Devil qui nous dit lors de
la config de l'iPhone j'ai suivi la
marche à suivre pour le transfert
Android iOS j'ai eu un seul souci
certains SMS se sont retrouvés coupés un
côté mon numéro de l'autre le
correspondant why je n'ai aucune
explication en ça c'est très étrange ce
qui t'arrive très très étrange que
penses-tu de l'achat d'un iPhone 12 Pro
512 aujourd'hui en reconditionné j'en
pense beaucoup de bien je pense que
c'est une très bonne idée alors je fais
une parenthèse le reconditionner
attention on ne peut pas aller partout
acheter en reconditionné c'est très
dangereux c'est même des fois le diable
tout simplement parce que en réalité il
y a reconditionné et reconditionné je
vais vous prendre l'exemple d'une place
de marché qu'on connaît tous quand on
pense aujourd'hui reconditionné on pense
souvent back market je n'ai absolument
rien contre back market parce que c'est
une boîte française et c'est très bien
ce qu'ils ont fait mais c'est une place
de marché il y a à boire et à manger il
y a des gens très sérieux qui sont
dessus et il y a d'autres personnes qui
seront un peu moins sérieux qui seront
qui vont pas reconditionner en France
alors c'est pas une finalité de
reconditionner en France mais comme moi
je me situe en France t tendance à
pousser les gens à acheter en France si
vous êtes en France sinon n'achetez pas
en France bien évidemment pas s'app les
frais de port pour rien mais il y a
certains endroits où certains
reconditionneurs se poseront moins de
questions vont aller avec des des pièces
détachées qui seront moins bonne qualité
donc l'idée de retrouver un
reconditionneur sérieux c'est bien c'est
gage de qualité donc regarde vraiment
quand tu vux acheter en reconditionné
notamment sur back Market qui est le
reconditionneur où est-ce qu'il est
situé est-ce qu'il a pignon sur rue
est-ce qu'il y a du SAV derrière ça
c'est aussi important j'ai vu pas mal de
reconditionneurs français à qui j'ai
parlé je peux vous assurer que le SAV
dans tous les cas quand on achète un
produit c'est extrêmement important très
important donc voilà moi c'est vraiment
un truc que je regarderai aujourd'hui
Dark Dark nous dit que penses-tu de oppo
je pense beaucoup de bien de la marque
seulement aujourd'hui elle n'est plus en
France donc quand on va acheter au pot
il faut qu'on on pense comme ce que je
disais pour le reconditionner qu' pense
service aprèsvente qui on contacte qui
va être en capacité de gérer le SAV s'il
y a le moindre problème ça c'est un truc
important j'ai un Xiaomi redmi note 10
pro et je pense me diriger vers un poco
X6 pro vaut-il le coup oui totalement il
vaut le coup il vaut le coup totalement
euh hop là ça bouge P30 pro au top mais
problème mic du bas pour moi ah ok euh
j'ai un samsung A23 5G tu en penses quoi
ça fait un an et 2 mois que je l'ai il
est très bien très honnête Samsung c'est
souvent la valeur sûre quand on va
acheter des téléphones et que on n pas
trop technophile ou qu'on pe se prendre
la tête on achète la-dessus on est on en
a pour notre argent très très bien aucun
problème là-dessus
euh est-ce que sur le Samsung S10 plus
il y a encore des mises à jour dessus
euh
je suis pas sûr et si c'était le cas ça
serait la
fin si la question c'est est-ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui acheter un un Galaxy
S10 plus pour moi la réponse ça serait
non en tout cas c'est sympa de voir en
live avec Monsieur gre merci beaucoup à
toi
euh
Aurélien je veux acheter un nouveau
smartphone me conseille-tu d'acheter les
modèles de 2024 ou d'en profiter pour
acheter les mod de 2023 Mo moins cher si
pour toi la question c'est
essenuelle la question c'est le tarif
j'irai sur un modèle de l'année dernière
moins cher qui fera des choses quasiment
aussi bien vraiment aucun problème
là-dessus je change mon téléphone tous
les 2 ans ça me paraît correct si tu
arrives pousser si tu arrives Alexis à
pousser tous les 3 ans ça sera pas mal
c'est c'est c'est ma philosophie après
je te dis ça je suis très mal placé
parce que moi mes téléphones sont les
marques qui me les envoient vois euh par
exemple Apple me donne un reprend son
iPhone tous les ans et me donne le
nouveau modèle comme ça je le teste au
long cours je le connais c'est mon outil
de
travail donc bon mais si je devais
l'acheter j'essaierai de le garder le
plus longtemps possible euh un avenir la
Vision Pro d'Apple je pens ah tiens
route Corse de B ça fait longtemps qu'on
sétait pas vu dans les lives je me
rappelle de toi oui oui oui oui je pense
que le Vision Pro d'Apple a beaucoup
d'avenir je pense que c'est une étape
intermédiaire nécessaire je pense que
c'est courageux Apple de le sortir tout
de suite marché est encore un peu loin
mais le fait qu'un acteur comme Apple
lance ça aujourd'hui va permettre de
démocratiser d'accélérer probablement un
peu les choses il est évident que s'il
sortent ils ont une road map sur de très
nombreuses années et que ça va passer
par la
miniaturisation aujourd'hui si on a les
moyens et qu'on veut garder un objet
collector je pense que le Vision Pro ça
être l'objet collector j'en parlais avec
un pote lere jour et je lui disais si
aujourd'hui tu as 3500 balles à placer
quelque part à placer tu achètes un
Vision Pro avec un blister tu ne
l'ouvres jamais et tu le revendes dans
10 ans 50000
€. je pense est-ce que je vais le faire
non je vais probablement en acheter un
mais je vais pas faire ça mais je pense
que il y a il y a des gens qui avaient
acheté des iPhones le premier iPhone
sous blister combi ça se vend ça regarde
si je vaux acheter un iphone
1 je mets iPhone
199 voilà ti j'ai un article de presse
citron Presse Citron Presse Citron
iPhone 1 sous blister est aux en chè le
prix est stratosphérique alors c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose il était vendu
600 € lors de son lancement d'accord il
est scellé dans sa boîte il a jamais
servi 50000
dollars un modèle similaire avait été
cédé 39000 dollars alors peut-être que
comme c'est le Vision Pro on peut-être
pas la même hype qu'a eu l'iPhone au
début iPhone quand c'est arrivé c'éit
des trucs qui n'existaient pas
aujourd'hui des casques de VR a même si
effectivement Apple nous le vend comme
étant un ordinateur du futur ce qui je
pense est le cas réellement mais
aujourd'hui ça reste un casque de VR et
d'R
donc je suis persuadé que le Vision Pro
c'est un truc qui va prendre de la
valeur si on l'a jamais ouvert s'il est
neuf il y aura des collectionneurs plus
tard plus tard plus tard faut accepter
de le garder comme ça moi ça me ça me
Hye en tout cas ce produit on on en
reparlera bientôt euh j'ai 64 Go j'ai
acheté une car mémoire ok quels sont
pour
ah quels sont pour
toi critères il faut regarder quels sont
pour toi les critères qu'il faut
regarder pour un téléphone pliable de
qualité al il y en a pas des masses de
téléphone pliable de qualité déjà il y a
ton budget qui va aider il y a les
finitions il y a la charnière il y a la
pliure bon et encore mais il y a
l'expérience logiciel il y a qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire avec moi il y a deux
formats qui m'intéressent il y a le
format qu'on va appeler le format flip
prend rien mais le forat
fold je suis m
et et et donc pour moi le le critère ça
va le critè ça va être ça déjàce que
vous êtes plus format flip format fold
je pense que le format pour un peu
monsieur madame tout le monde c'est plus
le format flip que le format fold quoi
que j'ai eu l'autre jour je sais pas sil
est encore là je plus si je vais encore
je sais plus le Magic il il est quelque
part par là le le Magic V2 de Honor
impressionnant la finesse impressionnant
vraiment génial donc ça dépend quel vous
allez
préférer euh c'est cher c'est très très
cher mais il y avait des tarifs canon
incroyables euh mais si je vais prendre
par exemple un un format flip je vais
comparer tu vois deux gros acteurs je
vais comparer d'un côté Motorola avec
son Razer 40 ultra et l'autre côté côté
Samsung avec son Galaxy zflip 5 je vais
préférer comment est intégrer l'écran
extérieur du Motorola Razer 40 ultra
mais je préférer les finitions et j'ai
préféré ce qu'a fait Samsung au niveau
logiciel donc pour moi c'est vraiment le
critère ça va être le soft et et la
finition quoi voilà voilà j'espère que
je t'aurais aidé Raphaël là-dessus
euh salut salut salut c'est qu c'est
quand c'est pas trop salut à toi salut
je souhaite changer mon iphone 12 12 Pro
max pour un 15 pro max as-tu des points
précis qui différencient de façon
importante ces deux iPhon ça va pas être
l'os déjà parce que c'est même ça va
être la photo il y a quand même une très
jolie évolution entre un 12 Pro max et
un 15 pro max je teur un 14 pro max et
un 15 pro max il en a mais bon c'est pas
non plus des des valises de fou là il
quandme y avoir une belle évolution
c'est quand même très intéressant je
pense que c'est c'est vraiment ça qui va
être qui va être cool et que moi je
viendrai regarder c'est cette différence
au niveau de la photographie les les
dalles évoluent aussi les puces bien
évidemment la performance que tu vas
voir à l'intérieur donc je dirais puces
et je dirais photographie c'est vraiment
le point qui pour moi le plus le plus
important
[Musique]
euh connais-tu les onepl nth 3 onepl
c'est ce que disais tout à l'heure en
fait he plus une nouvelle bonne nouvelle
donc bon comme j'ai pas les nouveaux
onepl je ne vais pas pouvoir en parler
euh il va y avoir pas mal de bons duels
cette année entre des monstres tu as
hâte de quelle marque à l'avenir selon
toi lequel sortira son épingle du jeu un
futur versus qui te plairait en fait si
tu veux il y a pas beaucoup de surprises
dans le monde du smartphone aujourd'hui
on attend des surprises c'est pour ça
que je suis content de ce qu'a fait
Samsung avec son S24 ultra moi je
j'attends réellement un truc alors déjà
je vais attendre de voir ce que ce que
va nous montrer Google avec ses
prochains pixels parce que bien
évidemment Google sont les rois pour
tout ce qui va être pour tout ce qui va
être comment dire euh il a maintenant ce
qui va être vraiment vraiment
intéressant c'est que je trouve qu'Apple
tout de suite en tout cas avec
avec avec iOS 17 est un peu à la Bour
par rapport à ce que d'autres peuvent
proposer au niveau de Lia il est évident
qu'ils vont proposer un truc de fou au
mois de juin et ça ça va être vraiment
intéressant c'est ça qui va vraiment
changer un peu l'histoire parce que
aujourd'hui quand on voit des téléphones
qui arrivent et que on vous intègre pas
des trucs dia de dingue ça me déçoit je
vous ai emmené il y a au mois d'octobre
au lancement du snap dragon 8 je 3 et
quand Qualcom nous dit vous avez de liya
embarqué dans la puce et qui nous montre
ce qu'on pouvait faire je me suis dit
c'est génial ça y est ça y est enfin lia
comme ça vraiment intégré ça va plaire à
tout le monde et et quand tu te rends
compte que en finalité que que au bout
du bout du bout et bien il y a pas mal
de constructeurs qui vont pas exploiter
cette a comme Qualcom te permettra de le
faire alors peut-être parce qu'il y a
des licences à payer qu'ils ont pas
envie ou des trucs en plus pourir des
implémentations mais en tout cas c'est
con quoi parce que moi je suis
consommateur on parle d'IA je vois
l'émergence d'énormément d'IA il y a
chat GPT à les compagnie et quand je
sais qu'avec un Snapdragon m Gen 3 j'ai
une intégré avec tout ça basé sur un un
lama 2 de de méta je me dit ok cool et
quand je vois que derrière ça suit pas
je me dis W alors on n'est pas obligé de
mettre que dans la puce he après il y a
des trucs en ligne aussi mais intégrzle
d'un point de vue logiciel bordel enfin
je ve c'est tout l'intérêt
quoi je sais pas vous êtes pas d'accord
avec moi
ah je vos
questions merci d'être là vous êtes
nombreus nombreux ce soir ça me fait
vraiment chaud au cœur beaucoup de monde
beaucoup beaucoup de monde je suis
heureux ça me rempli de joie faut que
j'arrête avec ce truc là c'est ridicule
ça me fait tellement
rire et après j'ai quoi d'autre c'est
quoi ça ça je sais même pas ce que c'est
ça je sens rien
elle me plaît cette petite console je
RAC même pas
comment voilà salut les petits lou alors
[Musique]
euh Thomas nous dit j'ai acheté un onepl
12 il y a il y a marqué livré sur le
site mais j'ai rien reçu la commande
doit arriver le 121 mais plus de
nouvelle plus de nouvelle plus de
nouvelle de qui de onepl ou de ton
livreur si il est marqué livré c'est
qu'il est livré quelque part quelqu'un a
probablement réceptionné ton colis
commence pas voir avec ton livreur il y
a beaucoup de blagues là tu sa pas
terrible Pierro nous dit j'ai pour
l'instant un Galaxy A52 j'aime beaucoup
la tech l'écosystème le système
d'explitation cohérent qui fonctionne
bien j'hésite à passer sur un iPhone ou
rester chez
Samsung moi je pense Pierro que si tu as
déjà un un A52 et que tu as tous tes
paramètres qui sont rlés sur ton
téléphone et que tu es rassuré que tu
connais bien reste dessus reste chez
Samsung si maintenant tu as un caractère
un peu plus
d'aventurierentuer on parle que de
téléphone ici tu peux aller acheter un
côil du côté des iPhones euh parce que
c'est aussi de très très très très jolis
produits à mon
avis cyberécurité 2023 nous dit du coup
j'ai acheté un Motorola low cost pas
cher et ça le fait aussi sauf la photo
et la vidéo c'est vrai que moto ils ont
eu souvent le problème sur le Pas Cher
des fois sur le milieu de gamme ils sont
améliorés quand même les dernières j'ai
vu des trucs vraiment améliorés même sur
en photo et en vidéo surtout en photo il
cétait pas très bon à une époque c'était
vraiment là B blessé et là ça ça
s'améliore mais sur le Pas Cher voilà
que pens du Xiaomi 13 Lite c'est le seul
que j'ai pas eu bon ça fait partie de la
gamme normalement rien de bien négatif
là-dessus attends ou là j'ai loupé le
truc euh merde ah Raoul salut monsieur
gr petite question j'ai un S22 plus je
me demande si je dois changer et si oui
pour un S23 plus ou un S24 plus si tu as
un S22 plus Il a 2 ans s'il a 2 ans il
est encore bon tu peux le garder
garde-le une année de plus sauf si ton
smartphone a un problème je pousse
toujours à garder ce téléphone et voilà
ce que je pense que
penses-tu ce qu'il fait jojol moi j'aime
beaucoup jojol j'aime beaucoup Johann
humainement c'est un mec super et et qui
fait des trucs très cool donc moi j'aime
beaucoup d'ailleurs s'il est là je
l'embrasse j'apprécie vos test et je
vais me demander comment vous
garantissez l'objectivité de vos avis
surtout quand les produits sont offerts
par les marques avez-vous des principes
pour rest impartial absolument Freddy
alors tu sais déjà attends je vais
l'épingler parce qu'on va prendre un peu
de temps pour répondre à
ça en fait l'objectivité des avis euh
tout avis est subjectif parce qu'il est
lié à ma rencontre avec un produit et et
mes goûts personnels donc ça c'est une
espèce de subjectivité en fait
maintenant je suis objectif vis-à-vis
des marques il y a deux choses deux
choses son des passes partout qui fait
il y a deux clé il y a deux choses il y
a des vidéos que je faire en partenariat
avec des marques et il y a des vidéos
qui vont être ce qu'on appellera edito
lorsque je fais de l'Edito bien
évidemment c'est sont des produits où
les marques n'ont rien à dire absolument
rien à dire si elles sont pas contentes
c'est la même chose rien à dire lorsque
je vais faire un partenariat avec une
marque qu'est-ce que va dire une marque
elle va avoir un droit de regard sur la
vidéo bien évidemment parce que elle
paye pour que cette vidéo sorte par
contre je dis ce que j'ai à dire je
teste ce que j'ai tester je montre ce
que j'ai à montré bien évidemment
dernièrement par exemple j'ai fait une
vidéo là-dessus c'est une vidéo qui est
en partenariat avec Samsung ça veut dire
que Samsung me paye pour que je parle de
son Galaxy S24 ultra ils m'ont dit ok
nous on veut montrer l'a ça tombe bien
il y a de l'a dans ce téléphone donc on
va montrer l'a on va regarder l'a ok
très bien donc voilà les différentes
fonctionnalités je les avaent déjà
identifié je les Avaz compris bien
évidemment donc on regarde je fais ma
vidéo je leur soumets ma vidéo il y a
des choses qui vont leur aller pas leur
aller je vais leur dire par exemple euh
il y a un truc qui m'ont fait supprimer
euh quand je parle par exemple suis au
téléphone et que je teste la traduction
au téléphone et je suis en train de
dire par
exemple il y a des gens qui me
raccrochent au nez je dis dans la vidéo
que les gens m'accrochent au nez mais je
le montre je suis là et je fais
raccrocher au nez ils m'ont dit est-ce
que tu peux enlever ça parce que en fait
ça ça donne pas une bonne image dis-le
bien sûr mais quand on te voit en fait
ça crée une émotion qui est pas bonne je
l'enlève ça me dérange pas parce que ça
enlève pas la vie et ça enlève pas
l'explication ça m'est déjà arrivé de
faire des partenariats avec des marques
où j'avais testé un exemple un des
écouteurs il y a quelques années je
tirais pas la marque j'ai fait un
partenariat avec eux et j'avais pas dit
du bien des écouteurs j'avais dit ok ok
ça fait le taf mais pas à ce prix là
pour moi ces écouteurs do être à ce prix
là et à ce prix là ça marche alors
l'agence ça passe par une agence elle
envoie la marque la marque regarde et la
marque ah
ouais mais non et on discute et
comprennent après moi je suis d'accord
pour faire des aménagements c'està-dire
des aménagements où je ne changerai pas
mon discours je ne changerai pas ce que
j'aurais à dire ce que j'ai à dire c'est
de la critique je critiquerai ma
critique est toujours constructive et
toujours argumenté mais si je ne suis
pas d'accord je ne suis pas d'accord je
ne vais pas chanter la messe ça c'est le
principe d'une vidéo qui va être un peu
plus testée les vidéos qui vont être je
dirais sur certains produits pas trop du
smartphone parce que le smartphone je
vais plus en profondeur j'ai pas d'idée
mais où je vais présenter un produit ça
va être plus factuel où je vais dire
tiens ça je vais vous présenter ça c'est
vraiment plus de l'ordre de la
présentation et et je donne mon avis à
un moment mais c'est plus de la
présentation donc donc c'est vraiment ça
donc pour moi l'objectivité elle est
extrêmement importante parce que avant
toute chose et ce qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est que je suis là pour vous rendre
service je suis là pour répondre à vos
questions si je commence à raconter
n'importe quoi à raconter des histoires
qui n'existent pas vous le saurez parce
que bien évidemment beaucoup d'entre
vous vont venir acheter ses produits
vous les testez vous dites mais c'est
quoi cette merde tu m'as dit n'importe
quoi et c'est tout sauf le but le but
c'est d'être totalement transparent avec
vous de vous expliquer les choses après
il peut y avoir un une différence de
point de vue de vous à moi moi je vais
préférer ça parce que si et parce que ça
et que pour vous ça vous touchera moins
mais dans tous les cas ce que j'aurais
dit je le pense voilà ça c'est important
donc c'est c'est c'est important tu vois
et et euh et merci de poser la question
parce que pour moi c'est important de
rester impartial et et je pense que les
marques qui viennent me chercher elles
savent ce que je vais dire elles
connaissent l'histoire et je dis pas que
c'est pas arrivé qu' a pas des marques
qui disent tu dis ça tu dis ça tu dis ça
mais en règle générale on BSE pas bien
longtemps ensemble on est pas d'accord
quoi et ça m'est déjà arrivé de dire à
des marques reprenez vos produits je ne
suis pas d'accord je ne travaille pas
comme ça c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave on fera pas à faire
ensemble on travaillera pas ensemble
c'est pas grave je
préfère travailler comme j'ai à
travailler et voilà pas pas dire de la
merde est-ce que vous jouez de la
guitare électrique oui oui absolument
faites Bob à
Karim j'en ai pas fait mais là-bas
j'aiel quelqu guitares au fond là-bas
qui sont j'ai quatre guitares mais je
passe pas assez de temps dessus c'est un
vrai live ou une vidéo live c'est un
vrai live amza c'est un vrai live un
vrai live moi je réponds à tes questions
je lis tes messages euh Raphaël nous dit
pour toi où doit aller les smartphones
où doivent aller les smartphones dans le
futur
euh pour moi les smartphones ils doivent
toujours en fait et et c'est ce qu'on
voit avec le Vision Pro tu vois c'est
vraiment ça en fait le truc et c'est
vraiment au truc auqu je crois
c'est-à-dire que c'est plus du weable
des produits qu'on va porter mais moins
de contrainte je pense qu'avoir un
produit dans la main c'est une
contrainte tu as un téléphone dans la
main tu marches dans la rue tu veux
regarder un truc c'est une contrainte je
crois beaucoup effectivement à la
solution des lunettes je crois beaucoup
à ces trucs là qui me parlent et je
pense qu'il y un truc vraiment
intéressant
euh tu penses quoi des billeur dynamics
dt 770 pro niveau confort j'y réfléchi
continue tu gères merci Quentin pour ton
message très très confort c'est vraiment
un truc que j'adore avec ce casque c'est
vraiment le confort qu'on a
effectivement sur les oreilles on peut
les porter pendant longtemps il y a
aucun problème j'adore ce casque j'ai eu
d'autres casques j'ai eu du Sony MDR
donc j'ai 75 06 je crois il y a
longtemps mais ça j'aime bien ça ferme
quand même pas mal tu vois ça te coupe
bien l'extérieur et c'est pas mal hello
monsieur gr plus 6 a rendu lame après 5
ans et demi quel smartphone me
conseilles-tu euh entre 800 et 900
balles si tu aimes Anael l'esprit de
euh onepl à l'époque je peux tenvoyer
chez noing BIM très cool 629 € en ce
moment
euh une interface qui est un peu
différente nosing 2.0 la glyf interface
au dos tu vas pouvoir venir
personnaliser créer des musiques c'est
très particulier comme téléphone mais si
tu aimes l'idée de noing comme tu as pu
le connaître ça peut être vraiment une
très très jolie alternative voilà
au-delà de tous les autres qui existent
aujourd'hui à mon sens
euh Sacha salut mais du coup quel
smartphone prendre après mon P30 Lite
quand il fonctionne a plus bien sûr que
ce soit Honor ou autre chose de
préférence pas trop cher - 700 moins de
700 500 donc moins de 500 balles euh
pour remplacer moi je te dirais qu'après
un P 300 Lite tu peux aller sur un un
Magic 6 Lite tu
vois je pense que tu seras pas trop pas
trop déstabilisé c'est un très très très
joli produit tu peux y aller pour moi il
y a aucun problème là-dessus euh
attendez est-ce que tu possèdes un
casque audio si el marque moi j'ai le A
E 2 de chez BZ qu'est-ce que tu penses
moi j'utilise beaucoup depuis 2 ans
airpods Max très bien après j'ai
effectivement des casques de boss de
Sony les WH
MX non 4 3 et 4 très très bien le 5
aussi mais c'est encore un peu différent
euh moi aussi je joue faisnous une démo
de guitare non non je t'assure ça fait
30 ans que j'ai pas joué tu serais déçu
on plus rien t'accorder c'est le bordel
euh quel iPhone me conseilles-tu pour
500 600 balles neuf ou reconditionné à
ce tarif là ça va être du reconditionner
bien évidemment je te conseillerai un
iPhone 12 en reconditionné là-dessus je
pense que c'est vraiment aujourd'hui tu
vas pouvoir trouver et ça sera cool
euh tu conseilles le Honor magicl je
conseille le Honor Magic 6L bien sûr
très très bien très très bien j'ai
planté des clous avec le faites pas hein
on peut c'est pour montrer la résistance
mais n'oubliez pas que tout smartphone a
ses faiblesses et que autant on peut
planter des clous avec autant vous
amusez pas à jeter partout parce que
même s'il est résistant à Mo are vous
aurez la blague tu vas tester le Xiaomi
14 ultra qui sera annoncé MWC tu seras
MWC je serai MWC je testerai très
probablement le nouveau téléphone de
Xiaomi quand il sera officiel et annoncé
euh salut je souhaite remplacer euh mon
X4 GT par le 13t pro euh quel conseil Me
donnerais-tu
et ben
enjoy voilà je pense que je pense que si
tu souhaites le remplacer le TR pro très
bien pas de mauvaise surprise ça marche
quoi JB salut j'ai un Galaxy S9
plus tu me conseilles de passer par A54
ou par un haut de gamme comme le modèle
s23fe ou Galaxy S24 ou une autre marque
merci pour ta réponse moi dans dans ton
message que je vois JB je vais
l'épingler ce que je vois JB dans ton
mess
c'est que tu me parles quand même
beaucoup de de Samsung tu vois Galaxy
A54 S23 fe S24 donc pour moi il y a une
tu as quand même une une je peux dire un
attachement mais en tout cas une
connaissance vraiment de Samsung ça peut
être pas mal de rester chez eux Onei
c'est une super expérience logicielle et
c'est très très bien si tu es dans la
gamme S tu es dans la gamme photo
performance productivité même si
effectivement S9 plus commence à
vieillir franchement un peu euh tu peux
aller sur un 54 qui sera très cool mais
si tu veux rester dans la gamme S moi je
te conseille le S23 feu qui reste un
tarif maîtrisé et qui est très correct
et que tu pourras utiliser pendant très
très longtemps le A54 est aussi pas mal
mais sera moins bon moins polyvalent en
photo vidéo photo que ce que tu trouves
dans la gamme S et comme tu connais la
gamme S reste dans la gamme S S23 il
fait très bien S24 si tu peux sera
encore mieux mais déjà le S23 fe il est
quand même super bien euh voilà mes
petits lapins euh euh je regarde un peu
message on va pas tarder à y aller parce
qu'il y a un moment ben il faut aller
dormir hein ou là là 22h8 je me coucher
comme les poules un su au lit monsieur
gre non non non bah demain j'ai encore
une très grosse journée de ta plein de
choses à venir tester pour vous plein de
produits qui vont arriver bien
évidemment
euh je regarde un peu quelques petits
messages là qui reste à droite à gauche
alors je vous le redis une fois de plus
là on est ça fait combien de temps ça
fait 2hur qu'on est en live bien
évidemment je suis très heureux d'être
avec vous euh très heureux de partager
ce moment de pouvoir répondre à vos
questions je suis désolé c'est compliqué
de répondre à tout le monde bien
évidemment ce que je vous disais c'est
que le prochain live on le fera avec les
membres et uniquement avec les membres
peut-être que les autres pourront lire
mais ça sera les membres uniquement qui
pourront poser les questions
euh aujourd'hui
[Musique]
euh vous êtes 10 membr c'est pas la
folie
folle si vous souhaitez que je réponde à
vos questions
le mois prochain et bien il faudra
devenir
membre si on a C personnes ou deux
personnes qui posent des questions bien
évidemment ça fera un peu moins de monde
mais je pense que ça permettra de
répondre vraiment à tout le monde en
prenant le temps
euh parce que sinon voyez là il y a
plein de plein de messages je suis passé
à côté parce que voilà il y a beaucoup
de monde qui laisse des messages dans le
chat et je vous remercie énormément mais
voilà donc voilà moment je peux pas
après si vous êtes 15000 membbr mais ce
qui n'arrivera jamais soyons soyons
clair de vous à moi donc voilà allez
deux trois petites questions vite fait
pour la route
euh je possède le casque de Sony W 1xm4
c'est un peu un autre sujet mais et j'ai
vu qu'il y a le 5 qui est sorti mais il
est moins bien que le 4 tu penses avoir
une explication ils ont changé leur
fabrication en fait ils ils ont pas
gardé le même le même form factor et moi
je préfère celui
du celui du du 4 je je vous le dis hein
du 4 et du 3 c'est vraiment le truc que
je préfère quoi donc
voilà voilà voilà mon avis mes petits
lapins sur ces casques là voilà allez un
plat
Bou hop
là hop attendez je je fais des manipes
en même temps je dis hop quand je fais
des des manipes comme ça au moins c'est
plus facile
euh qu'est-ce que j'ai pas vu me voit la
membre ah l'amperec qui est venu
bienvenue à toi bienvenue welcome et
merci euh c'est vrai que quand j'ai
quand j'ai créé le le le le en fait je
vous raconte l'histoire
différemment vous savez enfin vous savez
peut-être pas quand on passe la barre
des 100000 abonnés sur Youtube on a la
possibilité de rentrer d'être accompagné
par un channel manager chez YouTube qui
vous aide qui vous fait tester ce qu'ils
appellent des produits donc des
nouvelles fonctionnalités à qui vous
vous pouvez poser des questions et qui
sont là et qui sont là pour vous aider
et et vous aider à comprendre YouTube à
améliorer votre stratégie on parle de
stratégie mais en fait à mieux
comprendre en fait votre audience et à
mieux leur adresser un message à se dire
bah écoute voilà moi je parle de tech
est-ce que j'ai besoin je veux faire
évoluer mes formats parce que euh parce
que bah il faut faut il faut se
renouvler un peu dans la vie quoi
comment est-ce que je peux trouver les
les les vidéos qui vont vous intéresser
que ce soit pertinent que ça ait un sens
enfin VO il y a toutes ces questions qui
dispose et il y a quelques années 2 3
ans peut-être ce qu'il sont dit chez
YouTube ils sont dit bon on va lancer ce
qu'ils appelleent membership donc le
fait d'avoir des membres comme ça et ils
ont dit ben on va vous aider à le mettre
en place et ça et moi je me suis dit au
début ah ouais je pourrais faire ça je
pourrais faire ça je pourrais faire ça
SAF que le problème c'est que la
quantité de boulot derrière je l'avais
totalement sous-estimé et que ça prenait
un temps de fou donc du coup j'ai quand
même laissé la fonction de membre et et
en fait ce sont des personnes qui
aujourd'hui me soutiennent que je
remercie énormément et qui veulent me
filer un coup de main en venant membres
et quand l'idée de se dire ben tiens je
vois qu'il y a beaucoup de monde qui
m'écrit beaucoup de personnes m'écrivent
en me disant bah tiens Greux est-ce que
tu peux nous aider
pour tel truc tel smartphone je me dis
mais en fait pourquoi ça ça fait un sens
totalement avec les membres c'est-à-dire
que vous vous m'aidez moi je vous aide
on se file un coup de main on passe du
temps ensemble et c'est sympa je me suis
dit que ça pouvait être pas mal ça
semblea être évident pour moi de faire
un premier live où on regarde tout ça
ensemble et on le fait bien évidemment
ouvert à tous histoire de ben déjà de de
voir si si vous êtes là si ça vous
intéresse vu le nombre je me dis que oui
bien évidemment vous êtes très nombreux
ce soir c'est super cool et je pense que
c fonction de membership elle est coouol
al après il faut affiner voyez parce que
aujourd'hui il y a excusez-moi je me F
il y a des allergies je sens que les
pollenes commencent à arriver c'est pas
du tout bon pour moi ça début février
les pollen c'est l'enfer normalement
c'éit avril ça craint on a un mois
d'avance d'être vieux quand je comme ça
et en fait je pense que que c'est le
truc intéressant c'est de se dire ok je
sais pas est-ce qu'il va falloir
modifier un peu le tarif le mettre un
peu plus bas j'en sais rien je sais pas
du tout donc on va tester on se laisse
la possibilité de venir un peu changer
les choses j'en sais rien mais je pense
que c'est un un truc qui est intéressant
pour pouvoir prendre le temps une fois
de plus et de se dire que en en temps
normal je hop attende excusez-moi j'ai
plein de fenêtres qui s'ouvrent
notification c'est juste hyper relou
c'est juste hyper relou quand il me fait
ça voilà et et ben je la voyer je c'est
frustrant parce que je peux pas je ferme
ça en même temps je peux pas répondre à
tout le monde avec les membres je
pourrais vous répondre plus facilement
et puis ça fait un espèce de petit truc
contentre nous quoi voyez on est là on
se parle comme ça voilà donc ça je pense
que ça c'est cool attendez qu'est-ce que
c'est ma caméra elle m'emmerde PRS mon
chotteur il a bougé voilà et et voilà
donc c'est un truc à expérimenter
ensemble vous me direz si ça vous
convient si ça vous va bien si ça vous
va pas voilà il y a aucune obligation
bien évidemment d'un côté l'autre tous
les mois mes vidéos vont continuer à
sortir quel smartphone acheter au mois
de mars la prochaine sortira et bien
évidemment je continuerai à répondre au
commentaires donc soyez rassurés
là-dessus il y a aucun problème Louis
nous met membre depuis longtemps merci
beaucoup Louis Bruno David Bruno pardon
mais est-ce que tu penses que le gaming
sur smartphone va dépasser les consoles
je ne pense pas je ne pense pas
euh je ça dépend ce qu'on attend du
gaming sur sur smartphone versus le
gaming sur console mais je ne pense pas
euh j'ai vu entre le casque de chez
Apple et je ne sais pas si c'est parce
que c'est Apple ou non il l'air
terriblement cher pour ce que c'est euh
Kyan je il est terriblement cher chez
Apple c'est toujours très cher
maintenant il y a un sujet sur le fait
qu'ils disent que c'est pas un casque de
verre c'est un ordinateur et que je
pense qu'il y a une question à creuser
là-dessus j'en parlerai bientôt je
regarderai ça bien évidemment
euh en 2024 le pixel 7 est encore
envisageable oui oui il est envisageable
le pix en 2024 Adrien je t'ai rejoint
sur ta chaîne WhatsApp mais il n'y a
rien dessus vas-tu faire autre chose
Aurélien je disais tout à l'heure que
ver le cul qu'on m'appelle Adrien
Aurélien oui oui oui en fait tu sais ça
fait partie des des problèmes que j'ai à
savoir que j'ai toujours envie de faire
plein de trucs je lance des trucs et
qu'à la fin je suis là genre merde j'ai
pas la bande passante pour faire et que
du coup j'ai le canal WhatsApp qui
existe d'ailleurs si vous voulez venir
sur le canal WhatsApp je sais pas
combien on est dessus tout de suite mais
pas très nombreux et qu'en fait tu sais
je me dis des fois ce qu'il me faudrait
moi c'est c'est un community manager qui
m'aide parce que je je je m'en sors pas
quoi euh mais bon petit à petit ça va se
faire il est où voilà il est là mon
canal chaîne publique monsieur Greux 71
followers bravo à vous et merci d'être
là voyez bon je posste pas beaucoup j'ai
pareil j'ai ça sur sur Instagram aussi
sur
Instagram j'ai j'ai j'ai un vrai
problème de temps mais faut que j'arrive
à structurer certaines choses
différemment quoi
euh il est où le canal il a un peu plus
de monde 654 membres mais de la même
manière j'ai rien posté
depuis depuis le S23 fe j'ai hyper honte
ah j'ai honte j'ai super honte je me
raconte pas comment euh alors attendez
quelques petits messages et puis on va y
aller j'ai on a on a fait un peu de rab
là euh vous allez venir au MWC à
Barcelone je vais au MWC à Barcelone euh
oui d'ailleurs je vois qu' Sacha qui
avait répondu euh non je ne parlais pas
du casque vert leur casque audio oui il
est très cher leur casque audio c'est
évident tu peux trouver totalement un
très bon casque à moins de 300 balles
sans problème c'est très bien ce que
fait Apple mais c'est très très cher
c'est très très cher je dois le
reconnaître donc bon voilà euh
attendez les petits amis attendez les
petits amis je regarde hop allez on va
se faire un dernier truc là pour finir
le live je me mets juste
là hop
chat voilà c'est le bordel de mes côté
euh t
[Musique]
t en fait si vous voulez il y a plein de
trucs que des fois je je sais pas
comment faire donc je regarde comment je
peux modifier deux trois trucs hop là
hop
là fait du monde he dites donc hein vous
êtes nombreux ce soir
bravo bravo bravo
bravo très très
content
hop voilà hop là voilà pourquoi est-ce
que j'ai pas accè tout chat en direct et
ben
ouais allez voilà je pense que là hop on
n'est pas dégueu hop on n'est pas dégueu
hop on est pas dégu le mec qui dit
pendant des heures est-ce que tu feras
des tests du nouveau noing de quand il
sortira ouais ouais ça m'intéresse je
sais pas si c'est un test pas ce que
j'en ferai mais j'en fer quelque chose
ça c'est une
certitude c'est une certitude parce que
je trouve ça très très très cool
attends qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
bordel là hop hop hop qu'est-ce que je
fous là qu'est-ce que je fous là je su
voilà je suis je sors de mes lives je
sors je dans les paramètres en même
temps c'est l'enfer
voilà voilà je découvre plein d'options
en même temps directement donc comme ça
voilà allez on va se faire bientôt des
gros bisous je regarde quelques petites
questions avant de partir tu feras une
vidéo sur le poco X6 pro en en fait je
sais a en fait pour tout vous dire il y
a plein de produits donc je faisais des
vidéos avant je sais pas si je vais les
faire mais dans tous les cas les
produits j'en parlerai dans ma vidéo
tous les mois pour tout vous dire ce qui
reste le plus important parce que ça
permet d'avoir la vision d'ensemble et
en fait et puis autre point très
important j'ai fait beaucoup de vidéos
sur beaucoup de téléphones et je
malheureusement on se rend compte c'est
que beaucoup de téléphones se
ressemblent donc quand au bout d'un
moment je vous ai parlé quatre fois d'un
téléphone qui est quasiment le même que
l'autre le capteur change le processeur
change ille de la batterie mais
l'histoire est la même donc je préfère
qu'on se pose euh à ce
moment-là et
euh qu'on prenne le temps de se poser de
regarder dans la vidéo tous les mois
pour avoir cette vision d'ensemble
plutôt que regarder 4 C fois la même
vidéo avec des produits différents avec
juste le curseur qui est pas positionné
au même endroit et c'est ça qui est
frustrant en fait donc c'est pour ça que
il y a vraiment des produits qui
nécessitent des vidéos à part une fois
de plus celui-là en fait partie une fois
de plus celui-là en fait partie mais
pour tous les autres une vidéo par mois
ça suffira et ça sert à rien d'aller
d'aller vous inonder de vidéo pour avoir
la même chose voilà tout simplement euh
dernière question cruciale de la soirée
le Honor Magic V2 ou le Samsung Galaxy
ou le ou le Galaxy fold 5 c'est F de 5
aujourd'hui là tout de suite le Honor
Magic V2 tout de suite tout de suite là
tout de suite tout de suite tout de
suite euh voir ce que va sortir Samsung
j'espère qu'ils vont réussir à la finer
quand même parce que la finesse du Magic
V2 ça fait vraiment pas mal par je vous
assure quand je préparé j'ai toujours
des téléphones sur la table je prends
téléphone je dis [__] et je me dis
tiens c'est l'iPhone et là je vois que
c'est le Magic V2 je vois que c'est
l'épaisseur je dis allez c'est bon quoi
l'épaisseur elle est folle elle est
folle folle folle c'est tout petit euh
moi j'hésite à acheter un pixel 6 c'est
une réduction à 280 balles j'espère
c'est une bonne affaire pixel 6 alors il
a quelques années mais si tu touches à
un tarif mini mini tu peux y aller
attention bien évidemment en plus Google
il pousse assez longtemps les les les
mises à jour donc là-dessus il y a pas
de problème best youtubeur ever monsieur
grand c'est trop gentil merci à toi
euh tac tac
tac je n'ai pas pu voir une bonne partie
je ferai un replay les réponses à mes
interrogations seront sûrement là Nawal
alors naal poser des questions j'aurais
pas
vu ça ça dépend ouais c'est c'est
possible Nawal tes vidéos sur la maison
connectée serait des vidéos je vais
faire une vidéo Nawal sur la maison
connectée très bientôt ça tombe très
bien que tu en parles je vais en faire
une vraiment globale où je vais parler
aussi bien au niveau de la gestion de
votre internet moi j'ai différentes
solutions le stockage
l'éclairage la
sécurité la serrure plein de trucs
maison connecté vraiment de ce que j'ai
moi à la maison et de ce que j'adore
donc ça vraiment c'est un truc que je
suis très très fan de la maison
connectée j'ai des copains des très bons
amis qui sont des maboules là-dedans et
qui du coup me trouvent des solutions et
je vous assure que j'ai des trucs mais
fou complet ça va être vraiment vraiment
bien la maison connectée vous allez
kiffer parce que moi je prends un pied à
la maison et plus j'ai une maison depuis
pas longtemps j'ai vécu en appart
pendant très longtemps une petite maison
et là je me fais plaisir à la connecter
comme à ma boule je vais encore mettre
plein d'autres trucs hein mais bon il y
a un moment ça coûte cher quoi mais bon
ça avance quoi ça avance ça avance allez
mes lapins je vais vous
embrasser si vous avez deux trois
derniers messages allez-y le Galaxy S23
plus c'est bon il est toujours bon
aujourd'hui tu peux y aller allez
quelques questions en vrac le onepl 10
pro c'est encore intéressant je pense
qu'il y a mieux aujourd'hui Xperia 5
ou zenfone 10 zenfone 10 à mon avis
Xperia j'aime bien ce que fait Sony mais
le problème c'est
que c'est compliqué quoi c'est Sony
c'est Sony fait du Sony et ça va bien
aux gens qui aim Sony mais pour tous les
autres c'est
compliqué moi j'ai le dernier Mark 5 je
crois one Mark 5 je l'avais récupéré
j'avais rencontré Sony et tout je l'ai
eu à la maison et j'ai dit à Sony en
fait je vais vous le renvoyer parce que
je suis pas convaincu quoi je pense
qu'il y a des choses que vous faites pas
encore comme il faudrait le faire et
j'ai pas envie de faire une vidéo je
fais désinguer le produit donc je
préfère vous l'envoyer
euh bonsoir Monsieur gr je possède un
Xiaomi 11t euh mais je possède également
un Remi note 12 5G mais je sais pas
lequel prendre pourrais-tu m'aider s'il
te plaît bah si tu possèdes les deux
euh tu peux essayer de switcher moi
j'irai je pense sur le Remi 125g
aujourd'hui rappelle d'allerolis c'est
ma monde qui me dit ça va te coucher
gros tu es trop vieux merde merci pour
SL live je regarde toutes les vidéos
demain merci à toi Jérémy euh c'est
c'est quand le prochain live le mois
prochain c'est ce que je disais en fait
on va faire un live qui est qui sera
réservé aux membres donc il faut devenir
membre de la chaîne pour que je puisse
prendre le temps de vous répondre alors
bien évidemment là on se parle du live
quel smartphone acheter où je vous aide
à choisir mais on fera d'autres live il
faut que je trouve des des idées j'en
trouverai plein
euh pixel 8 Pro S24
plus
pas les mêmes puces exinos
stensor plus dia sur le ah je sais pas
les deux sont très bien tu vois il y a
un moment il y a un moment c'est
compliqué quoi tu vois de choisir si tu
me dis choisi entre papa et maman des
fois je sais pas tata tonton les deux
sont très bien je j'ai du mal à répondre
à cette question je suis
désolé pourquoi Sony c'est compliqué
parce que si tu aimes débrayer en mode
photo tu vois tu aimes débriller en
manuel et que tu aimes aller gratuit
dans les paramètres tu vas kiffer à fond
parce que là tu as vraiment de quoi
faire en mode vraiment photographe tu
peux t'amuser mais pour le commun des
mortel qui veut du point and shoot tu
prends ton téléphone tu appuies et tu as
de belles images c'est compliqué alors
autant ils ont amélioré la photo de nuit
vraiment vraiment par rapport ce que
c'était avant je en plus d'IA mais mais
mais vu le tarif et vu ce qu'on propose
ailleurs bon après si tu veux enfin Sony
dans leur Xperia one ils veulent mettre
le meilleur de ce qu'ils ont
crambravia euh l'audio de qualité
l'expérience gaming PlayStation enfin
bref ils mettent tout ils mettent tout
ils mett tout dans un smartphone et des
fois
euh ça manque d'efficacité et et quand
on voit le savoir-faire qu'ils ont à
Sony Alpha moi je me dirais en fait je
veux que mon smartphone il reconnaisse
tu vois comme là là tu vois je vois j'ai
un j'ai en vidéo je prends que Sony
aujourd'hui j'ai un FX3 là j'ai un petit
carré là parce qu'il reconnait mon œil
je voudrais avoir une netté pareil je
voudrais avoir voir un truc qui qui qui
qui va être aussi génial mais que sans
avoir un des brayur manuel que déjà le
mode automatique fasse la même chose que
les autres et qu'après si je veux des
brayur manuel je puisse le faire mais
avec des logiciels qui soient pas trop
compliqué ou tu t'arraches pas trop les
cheveux tu te dis pas c'est quoi ce
bordel c'est trop compliqué toujours
chez Sony c'est trop compliqué ils
veulent tellement être dans la
perfection du truc en pensant que les
gens ont du temps à passer pour non
voilà je pense qu'ils sont à côté de la
plaque enf mon avis en tout cas je pense
qu'ils sont à côté de la plaque
aujourd'hui son que penses-tu du onepl
vide j'ai envie de prendre le S24 plus
mais il n'y a pas le Snapdragon comme le
ultra il y a bien une raison peux-tu
nous en dire plus en fait je pense que
si tu veux l'année dernière sur les
Galaxy S23 on a eu que du Qualcom et que
malgré tout Samsung il fabrique des
puces exyos et
que les années d'avant il y avait avit
quand même une une disparité entre chez
nous en en Europe de l'exinos aux
États-Unis Canada il y avait du Qualcom
c'était des questions de deal en fait he
des questions de licence et C et ça ni
plus ni moins et que il y a dû y avoir
des Deals et des discussions avec
Qualcom en se disant ok nous on a besoin
qu'exinos continue à exister sont les
puces de Samsung elles sont là elles ont
besoin d'exister et elles ont besoin
d'être là d'être vu d'être commercialisé
et d'être développé pour être développé
il y a besoin d'un peu d'argent et sier
ça bien évidemment donc il faut que ça
Contin continu à exister donc il ils ont
fait un choix stratégique en se disant
S24 S24 plus exinos S24 ultra Qualcom
voilà ni plus ni moins je tiens à
rassurer à tout le monde l'exinos marche
bien ça marche bien il y a pas de souci
c'est sûr que on ira plus loin avec le
snapd dragon 8 Gen 3 mais ça marche
Nawal me dit merci pour ta bonne humeur
on est ton énergie tes vidéos sont
atypiques merci beaucoup garde la
simplicité surtout c'est très très
gentil merci beaucoup l'assureur il va
après le live tu l'as acheté combien ton
micro sm7b de chour trop cher je crois
que ça vaut 350 balles un truc comme ça
mais c'est c'est c'est du qualité
broadcast c'est vraiment très très bien
et voilà qu'est-ce qui t'a donné envie
de commencer les vidéos c'est mon copain
Arnaud C sur Youtube sa chaîne je vais
vous montrer
Arnaud Arnaud
C Arnaud
C c'est mon copain Arnaud bim
Arnaud qui m'a donné
envie qui m'a donné envie attendez je
mets là qui m'a donné envie
et et qui qui faisait du divertissement
aujourd'hui fait de la tech et qui fait
des vidéos très très cool alors c'est
très orienté plus plus PC mais si vous
aimez l'univers du PC vous pouvez aller
chez lui c'est un mec super en plus donc
voilà et puis en fait j'avais un blog
ENF c'est une longue histoire mais mais
bon voilà j'avais envie
had c'est pas beau ce que tu fais c'est
vraiment pas beau ce que tu fais euh
j'ai envie de changer de téléphone j'ai
300 € j'ai vu ta vidéo sur le poco X4
pro 5G il me donne envie mais pour
300 quelque chose de
mieux tu peux aller voir chez poco ce
qu'il y a également il y a d'autres
trucs dans dans les tarifs très
maîtrisés il y a ple il y a plein de
choses intéressantes allez voilà bon je
vais vous faire un bisou je vais y aller
euh quel est le prix d'un pixel 6a stp
monsieur Greux je ne sais pas
je ne sais même pas qu'il l'ont encore
le pixel si je pense même pas qu'on peut
le trouver encore chez Google 6a tiens
on là chez Google le tarif officiel de
Google 409 balles 409 balles tu
peut-être trou moins cher en
reconditionné voilà mes lapin tu as quel
âge trop vieux trop vieux att ma petite
voix bouge
pas je suis très viux ou alors je peux
faire la petite voix comme ça bon allez
bisous les lapins merci à vous d'avoir
été nombreuse nombreux à ce live
beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui a été
présent vous êtes encore plus de 200
personnes connectées en simultané j'en
suis très heureux beaucoup de personnes
qui ont été là dans le chat ça répond ça
commment ça laisse des messages
euh dernière information j'ai pas la ps5
je vois un message je sa pas j'ai pas
j'ai Xbox juste là à titre d'info c'est
ce que je vous disais on a fait ce live
tous ensemble le prochain live sera euh
pour les membres de la chaîne donc si
vous souhaitez avoir voir le prochain
live et bien vous venez directement vous
abonner et souscrire comme diraient les
autres souscrire un abonnement comme ça
on se retrouvera pour le prochain live
du mois de du mois de du mois 2 voilà et
d'ici là prenez soin de vous je vous
embrasse alors attention que penstu de
Huawei je pense qu'il a des choses très
intéressantes chez Huawei c'est une
question très très longue faudrait
prendre un peu de temps pour y répondre
comment tu vas faire ton live avec
seulement les membres et ben s'il y a
personne si et ben on sera trois voilà
on sera trois 3 et demi voilà et puis
sinon peut-être que je mettrai le live
accessible à tout le monde mais que les
questions au membres comme ça ben vous
poserez des questions ou pas ou alors
ben vous m'écouterez faire des monologue
je je peux faire des monologues pendant
très longtemps faites très attention je
peux faire des monologues je peux tenir
très longtemps mais pas ce soir voilà je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous très
bonne nuit et à
[Musique]
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]